what do you want for christmas you could
have five pounds
or a bible the first person chose the
five pounds
the second person asked for the five
pounds the third person they chose the
bible and when they opened the bible up
there was ten pounds in it this is the
story that gets people that to like
discover christ
hello and welcome to trash taste season
two guys
look at this new sets hello you like
yes i'm gonna that's this is also from
now yes welcome back to trash day season
two i'm your host for today
gantt and joining me once again are the
boys
i say this because we've had like a
three week break or something so
it's like five week break we haven't
recorded a podcast like five weeks oh my
god
because like you guys have had the
privilege of seeing our faces every week
but we have not
talked on camera for a good three five
weeks or so right yeah i think it's five
weeks
yeah it's always been mainly it must be
at least
yes it's at least a month at least four
weeks yeah about a month and it's taken
a it's taken a
long time to build this set a lot longer
than i thought it was going to take uh
you guys have seen like the
kind of like rough progression of it
from hopefully the trash tastes vlogs
and also
the sneak preview of like the
sponsorship yeah segments where it's
just like a bare white
wall it's like oh wow the great upgrade
yes boys are having
i think everything's changed except for
the tv the
mics and this yeah yeah
but we're going to change the figures as
well the figures are eventually going to
be changed when we can film our figure
special uh unfortunately
uh japan's just about opening up so
maybe you will be able to film that so
we figured like what's what's one
thing that will make us really let
people know that we're
based in japan let's grab some japanese
screens
that's the most japanese yeah japanese
yeah oh
you live in japan it's okay we have a
japanese guy on it yeah yeah yeah it's
not cultural
exactly exactly i i allowed it
we asked joey did you ask me permission
joe is this cultural appropriation i
don't know i don't know it's fine
i gave you the j pass
[Laughter]
why do they absorb light so damn well
there's a reason why so many youtubers
use it and i finally understand yeah
there's so many sets so uh yeah
hopefully you guys like our
brand new uh set we've got new cameras
um
we just kind of like not new lights
we've got kind of upgraded every single
aspect yeah
behind the scenes as well so hopefully
it looks
clearer to you uh please don't stare at
my paws because i
saw them on our new cameras i'm just
like this kind of makes me uncomfortable
yeah yeah but now now i understand why
like movie stars like wear makeup
do i do i have to start like [ __ ]
moisturizing and like taking
i already don't know how i look in 4k i
there's a certain avion water spray that
you might have to borrow from aileen if
you want if you want some nice skin
i do miss the 720p days webcam where
your face was just so blurred and smooth
oh my god see every [ __ ] pixel on
your face does dazaki
make you take care of your like skin
face i don't know
i do skincare routine now do you i do
now who got you into it
um well it's okay what happened was that
when i was doing
4k and i was doing streams people were
commenting on my skin a lot more
okay so it is the upgrade to 4k and then
yeah literally the upgrade at four
[ __ ] everyone's going to be
commenting on our skin now so then i
i asked a friend i was like hey i know
you're you're really into skincare
obviously uh a girl
and uh they were uh i was like hey you
you know stuff right tell me which stuff
to use they were like
say no more i've got like 500 korean
products all right all right i'm like
wait
there's like an order yeah and there's
like i have to do like six things
but yeah sometimes i forget but it's
really long i have to put like a face
mask on
and then i've used that for like 15
minutes take that off and then put like
three different lotions on yeah there's
a reason why i grow out a bit
is inside my pores i have really really
bad bags though and i think that's like
just
just very unlucky and i use like an
anti-bag serum and i swear it just makes
my hair
bags it makes my eyes just go like this
bro i'm like
i've got like really bad bags as well
it's genetic as well so
it's like sometimes i have a good
night's sleep great night sleep i go on
camera and be like
you're going are you getting enough
sleep what's going on there and i'm like
i'm sorry
i'm sorry mum dad why'd you have to give
me these jeans um
the the bags under the eyes is a symbol
of how hard the grind for youtube is
like that's that's what i told my
audience i'm like i'm on the grind bro
sleepless nights as you can see like
when i do have sleepless nights then i
look like a [ __ ] zombie and then
people are just like oh
this is a [ __ ] necromancer right here
but like even on my best days i still
have like really bad bags
so i i just imagine the people who are
like connor you have bags like [ __ ] off
like you don't have back yeah right
like you have the most perfect eyes do
you really want me to be perfect is that
i don't want to be perfect
i don't have to deal with that [ __ ] i'm
i'm barely trying to keep my skincare
routine in check and
actually barely doing anything i don't
even know if it's doing anything
yeah that's what i i've tried doing a
skincare routine and i've i stuck on it
for a month and
i'll be honest didn't notice the
difference at all or
didn't feel too much of it maybe felt
like
a bit of a difference but i don't know
if it was like a placebo
i feel like there are a lot of
businesses made for our insecurities
you know what i mean like no [ __ ] and
so you know meline came to me uh our
producer of you all know
and was like hey connor um do you want
to go to this like salon
that my friend owns in japan all right
where they like do skincare stuff
right and then so i have like i said
before i have hemophilia
so i can't have like anything internal
bleeding happen to me yeah generally i
think most people
don't want that too no no no that's
normal now
but i literally can't have anything that
even risks it yeah yeah and so this
one of the skincare things is like may
cause internal bleeding and i'm like
hold up what's skin care going on here
is internal bleeding
so what does something maybe cause
internally so the first time i was like
may cause organ failure but you'll look
great so the first time i was like no no
no no i'm not doing that
and then afterwards they were like you
should try it it's not really that bad
it's just the whole medical thing of
vidmy
you know yeah i'm like all right fine
[ __ ] it i i guess you're right
yeah i did it so what it was is that
like it was like electrocution
like it was like plasma that's mainly
landing laughs because she's like it's
wrong
basically it was called a plasma shower
which isn't very comforting that sounds
like
those horrible punk bands right so that
sounds like an old from a league of
legends character or something like that
literally like an electric rod or
something that touches your face
yeah like i think it like strips your
skin i don't really know what it's doing
but when it would touch me in certain
places my face is like
they [ __ ] twitch and i just
and i was like what is this did you just
get tricked into doing electroshock
therapy
i think they burned my face and i paid
100 bucks for it
and then they did something else which
is like uh it was like a vacuum
and like fluid and it felt really
[ __ ] weird and it was like yeah
they were doing it on my face it was
going in my ear cavities
i'm like how much how how much is
skincare worth it like
at this point i was like i don't think
this however good my face looks i don't
think it's worth this
like i used to have horrible acne in
high school so compared to then
i'm taking this who didn't who didn't
have horrible acne in high school
but i had like mine was so bad that like
did you ever use like proactive
not like that's kind of it's like that
really famous like
yeah anti-acid yeah yeah like says that
like if you have acne just use that for
like a month
yeah you'll be completely clear i did
use it didn't do [ __ ] yeah didn't do
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah i was like i didn't do
[ __ ] so then my parents were like all
right i found a stronger option
and just tried the stronger options
nothing [ __ ] works i had to go to the
dermatologist and literally take drugs
for it did it work
it worked i mean now my face is clear
now so i'm just like
compared to that i'll take these paws
[ __ ] i had horrible acne i just dealt
with it
and then i was just like which one you
just don't oh you just let it happen
yeah i mean i also i think working at
mcdonald's didn't help
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah the deep fat
fryer i swear dude that that [ __ ] turned
my like
pepperoni face into like all like
giggles
mcdonald's kitchens are like 95 oil
humidity right it's like
that like kicked it into overdrive yeah
i think i don't know when it went but
early youtube you can see i had like
[ __ ] tons of spots right luckily you
weren't that sporty when i met you
though
no dude i mean when you watch this
episode go live i'm sure mudan's found a
[ __ ] pic of
me looking like i don't know like a puss
[ __ ] machine i don't know
i don't think you were that's funny when
i met you either i met you when i was
like 21 though okay so i think by then
it stopped calming down yeah yeah um but
yeah when i was like 19 years yeah i'm
glad
i started youtube after all of my acne
went away because god
i can't imagine because the thing about
that and i had acne because the thing
about skin
skincare routine you know i like because
we bought we all
care about optimization and all that
kind of [ __ ] right
there's just something about going my
entire life
having like taking five minutes to get
ready in the morning and then
adding a skincare routine on top of that
and then you you like
quadrupling that time in the morning not
even before you add like an extra half
an hour to an hour sometimes
per morning and i'm just like is it
worth this time effort that i'm putting
into
is it making a difference i don't know
that's the reason why i wanted short
hair
for a long time because i just like dude
it's like one wipe of the towel yeah
your hair's dry like that [ __ ] feels so
good when you get a clean like a haircut
and it's quite short and you just whoosh
dry hair yeah i'm ready i mean that's
why i decided to get rid of like
really really long hair that i had the
beginner trash taste because like some
mornings i wake up and i'm like why is
my hair still damp
that doesn't make sense yeah absolutely
yeah now it's just a bristle like
five minutes yeah like like your hair
moisture should never be part of your
routine that you have to like
put in and be aware of because that's
when i know i need to get a haircut when
i start noticing that my hair's still
wet when i want to do something else and
i'm just like
well i guess it's time to get a haircut
because it's getting way too much effort
to like gel and dry and that's why i
have a huge respect for anyone who has
long hair
and has to like deal with that [ __ ] yeah
and i don't know how how long did you
have your long hair for
uh way too long i think i had it for
like six months
six months yeah like it probably went
down to like maybe around here
yeah i mean that was during the trash
taste days as well
but yeah yeah once i cut it i was like
god why did i ever have that hair
it was so it was so horrible to manage
especially because i had it in like the
summer as well
so it was just like a [ __ ] sauna on
my head and i [ __ ] hated it yeah
never again never again people miss it
people are like oh i want the jesus hair
back
yeah no you don't no you don't know it's
disgusting how did you guys
figure out kind of like when's the first
time you figured out what kind of
haircut you wanted because
i went through like my entire life as a
kid have you seen yours
yeah yeah yeah yeah i i just i just kind
of like didn't know i
obviously put up the picture i didn't
know how to take care of my hair
is it obvious is it obvious what the
[ __ ] did you style that [ __ ]
it was you know what i the reason i
styled my hair like this
is because it was the hairstyle that
took the least amount of effort to style
[ __ ] off
because when my hair was that short like
my hair's just my hair just like
naturally spikes up when it's short so
what i need to do is get a bit of gel
put it in whoop whoop whoop and it's
done
that's the side of the gel mixture if
you did like you'd have blown up way
earlier if you did a how good
styles is hair video like i'm saying
like you'd have blown up like a year ago
because it would have been a one-minute
video exactly
couldn't get the ten minutes step two
whoop you could have a
ten million views right now he did that
upload it to giger
maybe i'll make a tick-tock
youtube short youtube have you ever
thought about starting a tick-tock
no no i'm already burned out with all
this [ __ ] yeah i can't do tick-tock
i respect for people who like start tick
tocks now and do content creation and
all that [ __ ] on the side it's like i
barely have enough time to [ __ ]
upload on my main channel yeah as
like as a kid i thought like oh you know
old people parents they just don't know
how to use the new technology new social
media
and like as i've grown older i've
realized that's not the case at all it's
just
we just don't have the time to get into
them or learn
learn how they work and that's just
that's just the end or deal like your
parents could probably
use everything you use um they just
don't have the time or energy to get
into something new and they just rather
stick with something comfortable right
i think i did open tik tok one time and
i was gonna make a video on it
um like actually using it and i got like
five minutes in and i was like what the
[ __ ] is this editing thing i was like i
was so confused i was like i don't like
this
i'm not used to this i'm scared of this
yeah maybe that's how boomers feel yeah
yeah yeah
yeah i was like oh what is this
unfamiliar territory delete
i mean i'm sure i could have learned if
i spared the time but i was like oh [ __ ]
is it worth because like it took me long
took me this long to just learn [ __ ]
youtube and twitter
and that that's like i i feel tick tocks
adding like
so many extra layers which i i
appreciate when there's a good tick tock
meme because
like a lot of tick tock i've seen is
[ __ ] but like when you see a good tick
tock mean there's
nothing that compares to the [ __ ]
levels of
i can't even explain it there's so many
levels of just meme and internet culture
like condensed into such a short period
of time i've probably seen some of the
funniest [ __ ] come from texas oh yeah
yeah yeah there was this one thing i
don't know if you saw it it was where
this guy
was uh doing a tick tock with his like
he was like introducing his girlfriend
the star wars day one oh yeah so today
is my birthday and i'm gonna introduce
to you my girlfriend
and then it's literally like the whole
holiday situation yeah it's so good
just like an extra layer just keeps
getting added
every every time and it just goes so far
beyond what you thought it would that
i just think it was [ __ ] genius when
tick tock's like that i [ __ ] love
tick tock
um everything else i'm an absolute
boomer when it comes to ted talk
because what is what i will say is that
like content
the content algorithm on tiktok seems to
be so far beyond
other platforms where it's so easy to
find content that suits your tastes
um whereas i don't know with youtube now
it's just
it's youtube seems to be going through a
transition period where it doesn't
really know what it wants to recommend
you should recommend you shorts
or long videos it doesn't know anymore
because the internet's kind of switching
it's also because youtube's just trying
to compete with literally every other
social media out there yeah yeah so like
when they added like the whole like
instagram stories replica as well like
i don't even know what that was those
were [ __ ] called yeah like they were
like
there was that and then the community
posts literally just twitter remember
when stories were just snapchat
and then instagram had stories and then
twitter had stories and then youtube has
stories and that
uh everything everything has stories i
hate the stories
on on twitter i hate the fleets i
[ __ ] think
i used it once and i was like all right
i hate it
i never use them i never look at my
friends ones i never post any i'm just
like get that [ __ ] out of here yeah
it's taking up real estate on my app i
don't know it's like another [ __ ] post i
could be seeing
yeah it's that amount of space that's
covered up by fleece i feel like do i
really need my tweets to delete like i'm
not really that like
into it like i don't i don't think they
need to be deleted like that's
just save it i already have like old
tweets delete automatically from my
thing anyways
yeah yeah it makes it completely
obsolete who wants them to be deleted in
24 apps because no one's looking at it
anyway if it was
a tweet that got deleted in 24 hours i
could kind of understand what that would
be useful for like if i'm posting i'm
going live on my twitch
yeah i haven't deleted in six hours yeah
that makes sense but
if wide is in a completely different
section i don't wanna like i don't know
yeah have you have you seen that uh have
you seen the twitter live streams as
well
well yeah and then also twitter just
copied clubhouse with the
uh well essentially the whole app and
just put it in twitter yeah which i
think it actually suits more
but i don't i don't know is that what
that is because i keep getting
notifications
of like a certain artist i followed
being like starting a space yeah they
started a space yeah yeah yeah i'm
pretty sure it's
just yeah i think it's kind of like i
don't use it i don't know
i hate it because i i i didn't know what
it was and
like some some some people who i like
i'm a big lurker online right and some
people
who i was following started like this
you know space thing
i joined it and it was like google has
joined the room i
when i just don't like some of the new
features they add i can't figure out i'm
just being unreceptive to the new thing
or it's actually terrible like i
i don't know anymore yeah because
sometimes if things
is it me that change or is it because
sometimes it turns out to be really good
and i like it
but then it's just not integrated well
enough in the start and i'm not really
into it because i remember i was like
that with the instagram stories as well
when i first started i was like what is
this
deletes in 24 hours yeah what the [ __ ]
the point of this and now i'm just like
all right i finna upload to my story
let's go now i think stories are better
than posts
yeah now these stories are great but i i
yeah maybe i don't know maybe we should
[ __ ] boom i don't know yeah whatever
pro it's probably the boomer
probably a boomer it's probably a 24
year old boomer thing yeah yeah
what can i say well you know how we
we're officially boomers now because
we've held a press event
we're with actual probably boomers that
have been on the same stage
as us they're like really important
people yeah
it's like legitimate government people
oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay yeah we say boomers but actual
official
like political like important people
have been on the stage yeah right i mean
you could just tell i mean if you guys
went on to the fccj channel which a lot
of you guys did i think
we had like 4 000 people watching us
when normally i think they have like
six yeah a lot of the comments are
really confused they're like what is
this can somebody explain
i think we were also really confused as
well yeah yeah so i guess we can explain
what happened
um what is the fcc j connor the foreign
correspondents club of japan yes
which i believe is just uh essentially
the foreign press
yeah it's like an organization for the
foreign press in japan yeah um
and a guy reached out to us who was the
interviewer
um called fred and he was like hey guys
i'm writing an article about youtubers
in japan foreign youtubers
uh talking about like depicting japan
and i thought too fair
that's that's a pretty good article
because i mean i feel like most of the
younger generation are probably getting
a lot of the information about japan
from
ours or chris or yeah yeah i i know i
know i got way more of it
from from that than the guys because
most of the guys are like uh you should
check out the kiyomizudero temple in
kyoto
and then go you know what i mean like
it's super generic no i want to see
someone like
do something really [ __ ] unique i
mean i mean like he asked us a question
about you know travel guides
right and i just i just when he asked me
that question i just thought
who breeds travel guides anymore no no
boomers
i don't you say that but even my parents
now yeah they've gone
they were like they were like i've
watched this this fellow
you know called abroad in japan
and even a lot of these travel guides
cite people like abroad in japan yeah
yeah
it's really funny now now it's just
instead of actually finding their own
[ __ ] like
chris found this really [ __ ] cool
thing you're going to check it you know
japanese on youtube but anyway so he
reached out to us and he showed us the
article
and it looked really legit and it was
going to be in uh number one shin bun
yeah uh which is a paper here in japan
yeah um as
as we all know we all need we need a bit
more like official backing
because uh two of us here are verified
on twitter everyone
isn't and the reason i got verified is
because i
had submitted the articles that were
written about me and the interviews that
had been
that i've done but uh obviously someone
here had uh hadn't had any articles
written about him yet so uh but now we
got an article about cash
i have articles i just didn't submit
them i submitted my wikipedia which
wasn't good enough for twitter
verification
because was it the day that you found
out you guys had a wikipedia
you uploaded pictures for each other
yeah
we spent literally like half an hour off
this track recording
just trying to update these guys
somebody somebody made a wikipedia page
and it's very meticulous and i was very
grateful for it but i was like why
didn't they upload a picture
yeah i feel like this is very easy like
just upload a picture yeah and then it
got removed anyway
yeah i was like i was like they're
legitimate looking pictures there are
pictures
yeah i mean we added each other's
pictures and then like less than 12
hours later it was gone
i'm like what the [ __ ] how do you get a
picture how do you get a picture on
twitter oh no it's
a wikipedia [ __ ] and uh yes he they
reached out to us and
he was like hey do you want to come and
give a uh do recorder like pseudo
podcast
at this on this youtube channel yeah and
we checked that out we were like whoa
there's like some heavy topics on on
this channel yeah i think the week he
sent it to something like lgbt rights in
japan
yeah that's pretty serious stuff and
then you want us to come on and just
clown and then ask
us about pizza [ __ ] crust i was like
you can tell that the trash taste
viewers were like had invaded the chat
because
like we were having this very official
um press
conference and then like i get asked
about pizza crusts
yeah little anime yeah literally the
first question it was like all right we
got some questions from the uh the
audience right now and the first
question here is uh
god what do you think about pizza crust
i just find it funny how
just utterly unprepared they were for
like the amount of questions that were
going to be sent
because i remember the the person
running it just came up with like a huge
stack of questions
and the interview looked at this being
like this is more questions than i've
ever seen in my life what is going on
right now 20 pieces of paper she's like
here's the questions and the guy's like
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
it was it was quite fun though i mean i
yeah it was a cool experience
and we were like and the guy i remember
the guy was like you know oh you know
it's on an official thing like you know
fccj is a professional thing that does a
lot of like you know press conferences
and stuff like that but like you guys
can just come casually because you know
we're just going to do it like casually
like you guys do in the podcast and
we're like
we're wearing that
i mean like we had there was that wall
of the previous people that had done
fccj press conferences because they've
only just started live
broadcasting them recently if i
understand correctly so but they've been
doing them for like years and years but
most of them have been private
and like we saw the dalai lama on there
miyazaki did i see trump on there as
well
like a very young trump was there like
[ __ ] the president of thailand
um yeah the ex-prime minister of
thailand i didn't know this because like
i saw
a picture there and i was like it looks
kind of familiar and i was like where do
i recognize him from so i
snap it send a picture to my mum and he
was like oh that's that's the ex-prime
minister of thailand so i'm just like
[ __ ] only the important people yeah
[ __ ] brilliant what's going on here
and then
imagine that wall and then the literal
front of the fccj building is this giant
billboard this is like
tonight on fccj trash taste
that was so [ __ ] weird because it's
like
we should not belong on this billboard
yeah i i think as well uh
the journalist fred was like i want to
just be like a normal trash this episode
and i'm like i don't think we can do
that that's not enough
that's how it works i don't think we can
just cut turn up here
and just do a normal trash i think i
think i'm gonna have to be polite
like was he expecting us to like rock up
and be like oh you dk
yeah because like i saw a lot of the
comments be like this is the most
calmest and most polite i've ever seen
the boys well
yeah if you'd seen the stage that we
were on you probably act the same as
well honestly
who was on this stage before us then you
would probably act like that as well
i sort of comment that really made me
laugh and it was like that that
had the the watermen's doing god's work
not a glass empty for a single second
i was so awkward as well because you're
just sitting there and then this guy
just creeps over with you
like like bent over and i'm like oh i
feel so bad for you i'm like i don't
need water i was like
why are you
okay like i dead ass was like holding on
to that [ __ ] for dear life you could
have done it before you started the
sentence 30 minutes
you started the session i was like i was
like i'm going to go for as long as i
can
and i think about an hour into because
it was like a two hour yeah
about an hour and 10 in i was like i'm
gonna die like my bladder is about to
explode
before but but i can hold on it's like
50 minutes if i just concentrate
on talking and just listening i can get
through it
and i got i didn't forget what else what
questions did i get
you are actually getting asked like a
serious question in the middle of a
serious question and you're just like
sorry can i go to the toilet yeah yeah
did you even finish your like you just
went
and i was like what the [ __ ] like i
literally got like mental whiplash
because i was like oh this is uh joey
being pro
premium proper and professional but now
no way just busts out the
can i can i go to the toilet you can
hear the very moment my heart just snaps
and i'm just like
you have to go i was like i'm gonna cut
this into short i have to [ __ ]
otherwise i'm about to piss on stage in
front of four thousand people
i'll be honest when you asked to go to
the toilet i looked to you and i was
like
should i do it should i do it no hold on
hold on i was like oh did you guys that
i'm like i can't be the only one who's
busting for a piece like oh
my god should be dying right i was dying
like in inside like
my my leg was like going on like [ __ ]
sonic speeds it was just like
come on come on i was like i was like
water boy if you come near me one more
time and fill up that glass i'm going to
kill you
i don't need i stop drinking water for
the past 30 minutes
because if i drink one more sip of water
i am going to explode
stop filling up my glasses can you help
me the bottle
just give me a bottle of water i just
drink in this slowly
this is going to be a really question
but can you can you uh could you get
under the tube
[Laughter]
yeah no i could have man i was like i i
was like do i
just ask the question or do i piss on
stage i'mma ask the question
[ __ ] it he said he was like yeah this is
the first time it's ever
happened in the history of the fcc or
something right i'm like [ __ ]
there's gonna be another asian person
surely someone else there out there i
take his word for it jay i think you
made a
you ruined a a press conference or i
made history
by being the only person there's a lot
of people who made history
a lot of people made history on the fcc
but no one's ever taken a piss break in
the middle of one
i gotta ask what did you guys write in
the guest book because uh i
remember so we we had to sign a guest
book right right
so every guest who's been on there has
to like right sign it and write some
kind of message or something
and we we had some really like deep
important messages you know some talking
about some
very you know hot political topics right
now some people
some i think one message i saw was said
something like
we must listen to the voice of the
people yeah the people
will not go unheard and there's only so
long that we can stop listening to them
and so or something along those lines
and then i turn the page and it's just
my message being like
senjighara best girl giggup 2021.
at least like you came up with like a
kind of funny one like
i saw that and i was like i can't top
that why wouldn't you write
i think i wrote something like i like
anime yes i do
is that the same thought process that
you went through when you came up with
the anime
yeah yeah literally yeah i like anime
yes i'm doing anime yes i do
joey the anime in business 2021 i just
put i don't know what i'm doing here
it's literally all i write i mean that's
probably the most honest probably the
most
i don't know what i'm doing here connor
not even your full name i don't know
what i'm doing here
it was a great experience it was super
weird to be on something
that official and i don't don't even
think like our fans knew how official it
was
um when they were watching we didn't we
didn't even say anything about it until
like 10 minutes before we like should we
tweet out that we're doing this yeah
it's been live streaming yeah now it's
the most viewed video on their channel
as well probably by the time this video
is live it's well over half a million
views
i think so yeah pretty i mean it's
pretty insane i mean it was just
basically like a trash taste episode but
just
like polite yeah the gentleman i didn't
like all the memes which are like oh
damn
pog to the new studio center all the
budget yeah
that's where all the budget went yeah it
wasn't the trash taste episode it was
the garbage taste episode
i remember i saw i saw that camera and i
was like i was like weak
what a weak camera one one camera angle
one camera
this is a sony handheld what is this
come on
manual zoom in what is this yeah i was
like where's the lights where where's
the lighting come on come on look
look at this like this this floor has a
restaurant in it you guys can afford a
restaurant but not a good camera yeah
seriously come on
come on i'm kidding yeah we were really
we were really honored to be invited on
that and yeah we realized
much like i think it kind of set in much
later i was like oh i think we actually
did something like
pretty cool and legit yeah no i think
it's i don't know how many youtubers can
say they've done something like that
and i think we did a good job we didn't
embarrass ourselves too much yeah
yeah i'd say so i'd say we were i mean
we were way more reserved than
on our usual you know [ __ ] monkey
mode podcast or whatever
but uh yeah it was a great experience
and
one of the things we've been doing in
between building this set
i guess yeah yeah along among many other
things yeah
cause like what else have you guys been
up to nothing
this is the building of this office has
taken so goddamn long
and yeah it's it's taking a while you
guys will get the full scope of it in
the uh
after dark vlog which i think by the
time this goes up might be off
maybe maybe we still haven't even
finished the after dark sets yet
oh yeah we're still gonna build that
still building the afterlooks there but
we for the first time ever i think we're
just like one week
behind like our actual trash based
episodes which is the closest we've
gone from like actually catching up to
our backlog yeah um so
i think i think we've only been like
this at the very beginning of crash day
trash taste episode one yeah literally
sir why next i think
yeah i can't remember but i know that we
always have like a buffer this is
definitely the closest we've ever gotten
yeah losing that buffer but i i mean the
reason why we have a buffer anyway is so
that if we miss a week or we need to do
something it's not a big deal um and we
don't
really talk about current events a lot
of the time yeah
and our audience gets that whenever we
do talk about current events yeah it's
very
very uh outdated by the time it comes
later yeah yeah
oh hi didn't see you there hi it's me
monkey from trash taste i'll be doing
the address for today's episodes
and this first one is from a personal
favorite of mine expressvpn
watching netflix while not using
expressvpn is like paying for a gym
membership and
only using the treadmill it's a waste
expressvpn does a big brain move
and lets you change your location to
anywhere in the world so that your
internet
thinks you're in another country and
there's over 100 servers in multiple
different countries if you're like me
and want to watch
other countries content expressvpn is
perfect for you i miss the bbc
don't take that out of context and i
just want to watch my home tv
programming but
sadly you can only watch it in the uk
but thanks to expressvpn
that's no longer a problem anymore and i
barely noticed that it's always on and
it's super easy to use it just takes one
click and you're connected to a server
and it's seamless and it works on my
phone
tablet fridge probably and my pc and
don't forget that it encrypts all of
your data carefully so what are you
doing you know you're paying full price
for all these streaming content websites
and you can't get the full library don't
forget to use our link down below
expressvpn.com
trash taste and you shall receive three
months
extra for free using expressvpn so don't
forget to use our link expressvpn.com
to get three months for free of
expressvpn back to the episode
yeah you had yet another crazy taxi
experience didn't you connor i did
i did i'll send uh i wish i could send
you the picture
of like the route i took but i'll i'll
do like a fake
like drawing of it for this because if i
show you actually the route you'll know
where
you know kind of just dock seeing where
we're going i don't know where my studio
is and where i go to school essentially
this guy took what should have been a 10
minute journey yeah yeah and did it
45 minutes so um
what's up with that but i mean this is
the thing right so
i you know what happened was is that
this wasn't like a miscommunication
fault or anything because
i didn't tell him where to go the app
tells him where to go because i was
using a ride sharing app right so
yeah literally when he picks me up he he
has to say oh okay
this is where i pick him up this is
where i'm going yeah and then when he
when he
you know when he says he's picked me up
it'll tell him on the thing where to go
all right and i got in the car and i saw
where it was telling him to turn and do
all that and it was yeah where i told
him to go all right
and for some reason this guy just you
know ignored the turn and i was like
okay
whatever like there's a better roof
right maybe he knows
you know because he was like 80 or 90
very very very old yeah
yeah he knows that he knows the streets
better than the maps i'm sure all right
that's sure i'm sure
so then he misses the next turning and
i'm like all right okay
this is the next turning and i'm like
okay this is getting a little weird i
suppose some local routine
yeah and then and then he like and then
he misses another turning and this is
getting to the point where i'm like all
right this this man is just straight up
going the wrong way so i asked him in
like
terrible japanese i'm like where are you
going and he said um
somewhere in like roppongi yeah which is
like totally no
not where i was going yeah and i was
like oh like literally the opposite
like the opposite way at which where i
was going and yeah no no no don't go
that way
go the other way yeah and he was like
what what where do you want to go
and i'm like i can't hear what i told
him where i wanted to go and he was like
what and i'll show the app and he's like
oh let me put my glasses on i'm like
you're driving without your glasses on
you can't read this and you're driving
i'm like they do this every time every
time
oh this annoys me to death about taxi
drivers here every time
i show them on my phone where to go they
have to put glasses on and i'm like
if you can't read right why are you
driving
why are you driving without these
glasses on like you just what is this
blurs or what is this like you're
playing
like trying to like what are you doing
no wonder you can't see the [ __ ]
like navigation so yeah so he completely
goes the wrong way and i eventually get
to like figure out
to explain to him where i want to go uh
and it was just because there was some
weird thing with the address that i put
in where it wasn't quite what i said it
was right but
even though the address in the thing was
still correct but i had to then
reconfirm to him
that i was going to the place where it
told him to go yeah which is like why do
you even ask me don't talk to me just
take me where i want to go
are you sure you want to go to the place
you specif do you specify like this is
what i don't get it i told you where i
want to go
you know maybe you can confirm and i
said yes and then he's like what
what what i'm losing my mind right so
then you know the thing is racking up to
be pretty expensive because this is like
a 45 minute journey it's pretty [ __ ]
expensive
especially in tokyo as well yeah yeah
because you know the journey i was going
to take was just 10 minutes and it was
supposed to be like 10 10 15 bucks
no but not a big deal yeah it turned
into like a 45-50 dollar ride and i'm
like hold the [ __ ]
yeah and also after i eventually told
him where to go i was pretty stressed
out
yeah and now someone was on yeah i was
trying to watch youtube videos and i was
looking at my phone and then suddenly
the guy just emergency stops
like so i just my [ __ ] bag goes like
flying my water bottle just flying
i'm like yo what the [ __ ] this is like
the best bit
yeah i was like listen i don't know if
you're going for like the worst taxi
speed run any percent here i don't know
what you're trying to do you're
literally [ __ ] everything up here
he's like dead i was like a gta like
player
he nearly crashes the taxi and he was
unfortunately i couldn't see if it was
his fault or not right
uh it looked like it wasn't his fault so
i i didn't
blame him that but it was also just you
know also just kind of annoying
manchester here playing crazy taxi yeah
yeah he was literally playing crazy
and then immediately okay after this as
well i think because then he was
panicked because he was
like he'd taken me wildly off route he'd
nearly crashed the car he wildly [ __ ]
up
he pretty much [ __ ] up everything a
taxi driver could [ __ ] up right yeah
so he started speeding to get me to
where i needed to go
and i did not feel comfortable with this
man's spirit he just nearly crashed a
[ __ ] taxi
i was like i asked him and i was like ah
i was like can you go a little in
in japanese yeah could you go a little
slower and he would and then he panicked
he turned his full head around
no no no no no no
you know i normally am fully accepting
of the that kind of yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah okay you got you he was like
oh no no he's getting like 80 on a 50
road
i'm like stop no no no no i'm not going
to say anything i'm not going to say
yeah
and and then i was like i was like this
is the worst [ __ ] taxi ride on my
goddamn right yeah
and so every taxi driver in um in japan
has like their full
company information and name and
everything on the thing yeah so i took a
picture of it
uh and then and my phone has the in
japan every phone
has to make a noise yeah when you when
you take a picture and shutter so
so my phone did that so i think he heard
it i don't know
sonia he finally got me to where i was
you know one piece i had to like check
myself when i got out the car my
life right and as i was getting out he
like slowly pulls his wallet out
and i'm like you're trying to try to
bribe me to not complain
is that even legal probably not legal
i think i think so he was um he didn't
he didn't tell me
uh don't say anything he was right i
think what he was trying to pay the
difference
of what he went over right so it worked
out to be around what he went over
right right so like the fee should have
been like
um like 15 dollars it was like 40
so he gave me like 30 bucks and i was
like fine you know what
i don't want to complain to you i don't
have to do that because i wanted to get
my money back from the companies i was
like this is [ __ ] terrible yeah yeah
i don't know if that's me being a karen
like i just think that i don't want to
get ripped off
no i i mean i don't think it's like
karen to be like i
almost died can i have money yeah yeah i
cause i do i hate com
i do not i'll never ever complain about
someone who is doing like a job where
you don't make much money because yeah
i don't feel like no i get it i don't
think you get paid enough
to warrant you know yeah you're losing
some money like
you know if i have if i have problems at
like fast food places i'll never
i'll just be like you know what i it
wasn't great i'll keep it to myself
i'll deal with it i might leave not a
great review but like that's not i won't
be like super harsh
you're not going to be like where's the
manager that that's the british way to
do things
you know like again you know i don't
want to make someone's life more
difficult than it needs
life is [ __ ] hard enough as it is but
but right there's a certain point where
i'm like
you have done such an awful job where i
think
it's okay for me to want my money back
well yeah of course of course and i feel
like taxi is understandable because your
life is in their hands
yeah yeah yeah and literally everything
was terrible so i was i was just going
to complain to
the not to his company first i was going
to complain
to uh the uh the app to see if that
because the app can normally just
because he'll still get paid i believe
and then they'll just refund me yeah
which is what i wanted
um because f [ __ ] the multi conglomerate
but instead he just like
took out the yeah he paid me 30 bucks
and i was like sure so i gave him five
stars
[Music]
he he's like i don't speak any english
but you speak this language right
you know what i'm saying you know what
i'm saying i was like you know what i
was like
the man's hustling all right fine
literally bribed a five-star uber review
from you
i was like you know what the man the man
knew that he [ __ ] up big time and he
wanted to try and fix it i respect it
i i don't want to go through this you
don't want to go through this let's just
walk away you don't speak japanese but
you speak the ones
look at this all i wanted was the
difference back
yeah i'm happy to pay the taxi fee i
just don't want to be charged
like thirty forty dollars extra i don't
know i'm not like i'm not a lot [ __ ]
up no i get that
i feel like taxi drivers here are very
aware of that because
i mean most people in japan especially
in the service industry are
[ __ ] super off they do not rip you
off at all because i remember
um had to take like a pretty long taxi
that went via the highway but there was
like really bad traffic there on that
day
and so it took like i think like 20
minutes longer than the journey should
have taken
yeah and the taxi driver like he told me
that he was gonna stop the meter early
because he feels bad that they were
stuck in traffic for so long
even though they went via the highway so
i'm just like that's not even his fault
yeah that's not even
your fault you you're a real one man
you're a real one when you taxi you just
gamble man
maybe the highways are congested that's
yeah that's that's the risk that's just
part of the risk and i you know i feel
like just
taxi drivers or anyone like it's so
weird to me
that you can't tip people here because
out of every country that i've lived in
and been to
the one country i've wanted to tip
people the most is here in japan
yeah and it's it's just like it's
it feel it feels bad because i've gotten
some of the best service i ever have
anywhere in the world and i can't pay
them a bit more to show my appreciation
you know i think the only service in
japan that you can actually tip people
is uber eats
but that's just yeah that's integrated
but that's just because it's uber yeah
which is an international company right
i always tip if it's raining
i feel so bad for that when i order food
when it's raining yeah yeah yeah they
turn
up at the door [ __ ] soaked yeah
especially when it's like typhoon season
as well you're just like
damn man like three three dollars okay
three doors for your trouble sir
it was such an awful experience it was
just yeah yeah and i felt so bad because
i
i was in like i was trying to optimize
it so i ordered food
yeah like lunch uh to arrive at the
studio for when i was going to get there
and i was like jerry can you can you get
uber no because i was waiting at the
studio and and connor was like yeah i'm
10 minutes away i was like cool
i'll see him very soon then like 30
minutes past i'm like
where is he yes i saw that on the like
the message stream because i wasn't
there at the studio that day
and i was like why is connor telling
joey to get his food yeah like this this
white boy gave more privilege
every day
jesus christ man that's why i'm always
scared man to get on taxis because it's
like
again it's like in japan 85
of the time they're like over the age of
70. and i and i just don't know what to
expect
it's like some sometimes they're the
most like pristine proper like you know
[ __ ]
batman's assistant levels of like
amazing driving but then
sometimes you get people like that right
where it's like you shouldn't be behind
a steering wheel yeah i had a guy one
time i got in the car she started
thinking like fluid english to me and i
was like well
he's like are you comfortable with the
ac
what are you doing doing doing being a
taxi driver yeah i was so confused i was
like
i was just so caught off guard by it i
was like i was like yeah yes yeah it's
great it's great well
they don't ask you anything normally if
someone's below the age of 60
they do they like you rarely see someone
below the age of 60 be a taxi driver
especially here in japan um oh i should
give you a life hack for if you ever
come to japan use taxis
okay they're only ever gonna ask you
like two things
is it like where you're going and do you
want to use the highway yeah and that'll
always be the second question just say
yes
just always say yes don't say no just
just
okay so once once you've told them where
you're going right like even if you
don't understand what the [ __ ] they're
saying
all right so once they figured out where
you're going like yeah
about like five minutes into your drive
they'll turn around and ask you
something and just say yes because
they're going to ask you about the
highway
that's just the japan life hack yeah if
i don't understand what someone's saying
i just say
just say hi like this you remember this
if you come to japan remember this he's
gonna ask you something two minutes in
five minutes into the taxi drive he he's
he's gonna be in the middle of driving
just say yes he's asking if you want to
go on the highway just say yes like
someone could have could have probably
asked me if i could be like an
accomplice and a murderer i've said yes
to win
like in japan probably you don't know
because i've just said yes to everything
like the only time i know
i have to actually pay attention is when
i was like are you sure about that
yeah do you know did you know did you
just press agree on terms and conditions
do you know what you just agreed to
do like a [ __ ] millionaire like final
and then like even when they repeat that
i'm just like yeah
because on the signs in japan on the
highways it just says expressway
they call it expressway 2. it's not
called expressway they call it what is
it
which is hot which which is direct
translation for high fast road
ah okay so there you go but i was also
told that they understand highway yeah i
was confused i never said highway
because it always says expressway
so i never used i never said highway but
they'll understand if you say highway
yeah
second life hack if you don't know a
japanese word say it
in katakana and
but it's then yeah yeah exactly yeah so
if you if you don't know if you can't
recast kinda
just say it in the most like racist
japanese yeah like
accent you can think of and they will
maybe understand you
sometimes because what i'm streaming in
it yeah i have to say
a word like that people like pepe laugh
connor just said it in like a funny
accident i'm like yeah no that that's
literally how they say they don't
understand unless i do that
i love how all these people yeah because
like everyday words i've just become
like more and more english now right
like it's like you know if say like
it's like um like spicy right like you
want spicy food
yeah no the japanese word for it is
karai yeah
you could also just say spicy oh are you
can't oh you can't yeah
and it's the exact same thing i didn't
know that it's like sexy
it's just security because like
it's just miraculous right yeah because
because like i learned uh what was it
what was the recent japanese
cafe which is like kisaten yeah it's
like the proper japanese word yeah
but everyone just says cafe here cafe
yeah
your grandma will say yeah yeah yeah
yeah grandma will say something but
everyone else will just say coffee
everything's become yeah so like i've
i've realized actually like in
in the place that i am now it's like
more easier just to say yes to
everything if you don't fully understand
it because i remember me and connor had
another taxi experience
oh no this is uh which drove me up the
wall
which was uh uh on my birthday night so
it's like after we hung out we went back
to mainland and we went back
to my house pretty late and we all live
in the same area so me and connor got a
taxi back
um and we were this was like at 5 00 a.m
we were very drunk and very tired
and uh so connor orders a taxi via dd
which is kind of like
uber yeah so the address is already in
the tax again he knows where we're going
he knows where he tells him pinpoint
location yeah yeah where to go and how
to get there
yeah yeah so we get in the taxi and he
asks us
oh where do you want to go so i didn't
know that
he had already had the address because
he did already have the address and he
was in his system
so i tell him please go to this address
right and well i think you said the
station near our house i think that's
when he got confused because then that
was
oh yeah yeah yeah now he's like wait is
it the station or the address and
bear in mind they're like literally two
minutes away from yeah so i'm like just
go there and it'll be all right both of
the addresses in the exact same place
just go there yeah and so i think then
he started getting really like he's like
wait which one though
and then every five minutes this man
would turn around and ask which one are
you
like oh here yeah here yeah and we're
like yes
yes yeah and i was i was trying to
explain to him it's i just it's near the
station it's near the station yeah right
right and he's just like
but it's a different address where do
you want me to go i was like
just go to like my japanese wasn't good
enough to say go to this exact address
my i was just like just go
near the station and we'll like direct
you and he was like
am i going the right way do these taxi
drivers not have like freedom of choice
it's literally the same road it's not
even remotely far
like yeah it's like a computer trying to
run two programs at the same time it's
like which one do i have
i don't know it's like i literally get
he was like an ai and i just gave him a
logic bomb
that's like that's how he acted and i
was just like and i just thought to
myself like this is not on the taxi
driver because obviously it was just
like a language barrier but
i just thought to myself i should have
just said hi yeah
i should have just said yes yeah and
just said yes please go to the address
you didn't use the life hack
yeah yeah yeah he said hi like seven
times in a row and then he still did
keep
asking and i was like yeah because he
probably because he probably asked like
do you want to go to the station you're
like hi
or did you want to go to the house hi
which one though yeah we used to we used
the lifestyle
but also everything we said to him he
was clearly like you know he was
quite old and his hearing was clearly
not great right
everything we said we had to repeat but
louder yeah yeah
and i feel like some things we said
pretty [ __ ] loud yeah he didn't he
didn't like
understand and i was like well maybe
that was just like you're
like maybe in your guys's drunk mind you
were like hi
i was so but in reality it was like i
was very very sober at this point
because i was just trying to sleep
right yeah he kept waking us up and i
was like
i'm fine for my life just to get like
five minutes of sleep sydney was sitting
next to me she doesn't remember any of
it she was like
past the phone oh my god this is like
i'm like silly kept making it worse
because city was drunk saying things
like city shut up literally shut up
you're confusing the man
completely like she literally kept
making it work it was i was i was
literally about to be like
tell her get sydney to shut up
because she was clearly like not even
awake and she would be like i'll [ __ ]
the dice
not even there she would sell it oh he's
fine
all right keep going and we're like
we're like nowhere near oh he's fine
yes no city please play please she was
dream japanese talking
because it was like it was like she was
speaking japanese that was off enough
that it made no sense like in the
context they were in but it made enough
sense that someone would say it in a
taxi right right
all the correct things you would say in
a taxi i remember i'd keep going like
sydney
please stop silly stop oh my god yeah
but yeah we eventually got home
after what it felt like two hours away
did he drop you off the station on your
house
okay he finally came over i didn't even
want to try and direct him to my house
let's just stop yeah yeah yeah let me
know
let me get me out of here yeah i can't
stand this
yeah but i mean that's that's part of
the reason why we're looking to move
right
yeah yeah have we talked about how we
are looking to move because we've
i mean right yeah you've talked about
that i've lived already yeah
a month ago now this right yeah i'm
currently in the process of i've applied
for a place just hoping i get i mean i
found out this week so yeah praying i
get it i i think
re like doing the whole moving process
again
has reminded me how much of a nightmare
it was the first time to get a place
here and i just
didn't realize or i've forgotten because
i had everything set up yeah and now i'm
going through the process again i'm just
like
damn it was a nightmare and i'd
completely forgotten about it yeah
it's equal parts exciting equal parts
just dread
and so far it's not been too bad it's
been really annoying being rejected
for really petty reasons yeah yeah
that's been quite annoying but that's i
feel like i'm so used to that now or i'm
like
i'm not the right nationality all right
cool yeah
yeah um so i'm kind of used to it but
yeah
i mean how many places have you been
rejected from so far just one right
um two two two oh two um but some of
them were like
not rejections that didn't apply but
some of them were like oh no no furnace
oh just throw it off so is that like a
rejection do you count that no that's
original because that's like
i feel like that's like 10 15 and right
like half of them are gone
yeah yeah half of the whole like
japanese housing market is just like
unavailable
yeah i'd say if it's like even more than
half like even if you have the money
to pay for this house you just can't get
it yeah for whatever reason
we talked about this yeah episode 2 or
something
about like how it's [ __ ] impossible
for foreigners to write in japan
it's also you know um i feel like this
happens everywhere there you have to
kind of like decide like what's
important to you and you have to like
make
sacrifices depending on you know even if
you have like unlimited budget you know
there's not going to be
you know if you want to get a house in
certain areas this is not possible in
central like tokyo oh yeah i mean unless
you're actually like
buying the property but yeah you know
you don't have to do that right well
the thing is like when when i'm looking
at houses now like the first question i
ask is
has anyone else applied for this yet and
if the answer is yes i'm just like
well that like that's pretty much my
chances so
they didn't tell me this but apparently
if someone else has applied the odds of
you getting it are like super low
because it's normally just first come
first serve yeah yeah
and if the person before you japanese
they're probably not going to get
rejected unless they're like super
sketchy
yeah yeah so if someone yeah like you
said they they took me to see
places and half them would already been
applied for and i'm like what am i doing
here
what so you can and of course the two
places check out this place you probably
won't get so the first
the first place they took me to visit
was five houses and the two that i
really really liked of course were the
two that had applications so i was like
great so now i've fallen in love with
two places and i can't [ __ ] help them
right
like a little cocktails now you've shown
me what my standards are
and you've taken them away it's like
this is what you could have if you had a
japanese passport
hello so and so then
they i was like okay well i don't like
the other three and so we could
we find new ones yeah we found new ones
didn't like any of them and i was like
well this sucks because i don't like any
of these [ __ ] yeah
and eventually found a few that i kind
of liked uh and i've applied for one
that i quite like
um maybe neighbors might be an issue
we'll find out but i'm gonna just sound
proof to the room before i move anything
well again that you know that's a that's
a sacrifice you have to take
yeah it's pretty [ __ ] hard i mean you
know i think we're gonna have neighbors
yeah of course the one sacrifice i took
with my place is that like it's just
slightly kind of
out of the way especially when you go to
tokyo but everything else is [ __ ]
it's a great house yeah yeah yeah i mean
i'm just planning to put like soundproof
panels on the wall and i'm just going to
put them on the side walls
you got your first noise complaint
didn't you i did get a noise complaint
yeah after all this time
i know i was definitely pushing it to be
fair i think because you know when i
first moved in
i like we wouldn't even like walk at
full speed around the house
because i'd heard how careful i had to
be yeah and then i realized oh nothing's
happening
oh so i start walking normally you know
so you kept testing the limit
and then and then the apex stream starts
getting later and later
apex at 2 am streams did the push it
over the limit i don't know what it was
that did it because when i got the
complaint i hadn't done
any late night streams that i would say
were loud like i think they had only
done
one and it was very very quiet one i
know it was because i was just talking
so i wondered what did it because there
was somewhere else full on shouting at
like 2 a.m
yeah and i didn't get it i mean we got a
noise complaint at our place but
a week speed run yeah but a week after
the actual event that it happened so i'm
just like
why am i getting the complaint now after
a week i think as it goes to the agency
then the agency tells you right
but the agency like has my number on
speed dial so it's like they could
easily have just like
called me the next morning being like uh
were you allowed
to snitch bro it's kind of cringe no no
because
we got you bro don't worry about legit i
was like who said it
i was literally like liam neeson from
tech i'm like who's saying yeah
they won't tell you like i i i
understand privacy reasons but also
i'd like to know so that i can kind of
like maybe put some stuff on that right
right because like if i know who it is
at least because they didn't even tell
me if it was like someone from tell me
who's a little [ __ ]
so i can soundproof that sound no
because like if i knew it was like say
the neighbors downstairs then i could be
like oh okay maybe i should you know do
some padding on the floor or something
like that or like thick ass carpet or
something to avoid it or if it's like
people across the road well then it's
like well i can't do [ __ ] anything
about that so yeah i guess we'll just
like what is this the fcc
oh my god you gotta you gotta be the
water yeah
like if i knew who the neighbor was then
i could you know
take precautions and you know work so
that i don't have to you know i almost
understand that like
if it was me complaining i probably
wouldn't want to be named but also
you could maybe i don't need to know the
specific person i just need to know
it's like is it a neighbor below me is
it someone across the road
is it in this building i don't know i
guess they're worried about you might go
to him be like yo open the [ __ ] why are
you complaining a little [ __ ]
why are you complaining to my face
[ __ ]
but then also you could be like hey man
um could i ask like
when you need me to be quiet yeah you
know is there like stuff going because
like you know
if my neighbors dude they can shout all
they [ __ ] want yeah
i i i don't give a [ __ ] yeah but you
know if i was
you know if i had a kid or something
then maybe you know i'd be like hey keep
it down after 10. you know that's the
problem it's like
yeah because if that was me and i was
getting noise complaints from say
someone from upstairs
i just [ __ ] got up to them being like
hey i'm not like gonna snitch on you or
something like
can we just like talk it out so that we
can come to some kind of mutual
agreement but yeah
in japan no one [ __ ] does that yeah
they're just like ring ring help me
please
but but i asked i asked like what can
they do like what can they do with this
complaint what happens they were like
they can like technically get you
evicted if they like tried really
freaking hard especially if you're a
foreigner
because i mean you know like that from
my last place that woman downstairs
tried to do that
i'm like how [ __ ] hard do they have
to try to get me evicted though like i
said like how much effort does it have
to go through and i think they said it
was like it was like a lot of work and
it probably wouldn't happen so i was
like
well i'm not i'm not that bad i'm not
i'm not shouting all the time
i have uh turned my volume down during
this year unless unless you're not doing
like construction or like 2 a.m
but i think i've done like they clearly
don't care during the day because i've
done like voice lines
during the day where i'm full on
screaming yeah like no they're not okay
during the day it's only a night
i bet some neighbors do care during the
day they're like i mean
yeah oh god i'm uncomfortable maybe i'll
go maybe on a weekend what is that
voice actor i just thought someone was
getting murdered up there yeah the
uh the agent who is finding me my
apartment
yeah i watched her youtube i didn't tell
her my youtube right but they had to
know my company yeah
of course and so i think she just went
on the company so i saw my name she
watched my youtube
i was like oh god well you just got are
you youtuber youtube yeah i was like oh
cool what did
which one did you watch and she was like
i watched you drinking alcohol and i was
like
with chris and i'm like oh my god
what a terrible introduction to me like
here's what i do for a job i get
sloshed on camera this was you filming
this in your house yeah yeah yeah yeah
so do you film all the videos i'm like
i'm like oh
i'm like it's very rarely it's very i
got a studio you
i know i film a lot outside you know
rarely film indoors you know honestly
i'm barely talking frankly no that's how
i got my place yeah i literally had to
like
tell the people who i was applying it to
they were like you can't tell them
anything yeah
so because they like the person who owns
my place
like watch my youtube because like they
had to know as well because i was
applying under my company so they were
like
so are all your videos filmed inside i'm
just like no no most of these are
outside and they're like okay
to be fair i never record past like five
six pm
anyway it's just streams which again i
mean i remember you
you said before in london you used to
record like 2 a.m or 3 a.m my neighbors
didn't give a [ __ ] though but then again
they were blasting peppa pig through the
wall like 2 a.m so i don't really
what kid is
understanding where like no complaints
yeah no police no police
because my neighbors had like 10 people
living in a house that had like two
bedrooms
right so i don't know how how much
police they wanted over there yeah
like that's why i'm pretty sure they
never ever said anything because one
time
uh multiple times actually i opened the
door to get a package from them
and it looked like you know like uh just
like
so many [ __ ] people were living in
there it was crazy i was like
it was very weird so i think that's why
they never complained yeah and also the
walls are thicker
yeah have you ever had like a neighbor
from hell or like a bad neighbor
like japan aside no ever in england i've
been pretty good
yeah i think you did you mentioned it on
trash taste but if i had sex yeah
oh no no no that was that was actually
that was that was up i enjoyed hearing
that that's oh that was a fact
we had a mutual understanding they could
have sex in the next room and i could
record podcasts
whenever i want and be a youtuber it was
great they didn't complain at all and i
didn't complain
from hell yeah i did actually it was i
never do things yeah it was it was
actually like the place i had moved to
after that so it was actually like the
first place i'd moved into with with
sydney
and we just had this guy living above us
and we didn't know this one
when we moved in but uh we moved into
this house
that was basically like a hmo so house
of like multiple occupancy
which is like basically a house that has
been like it's
it's been cut up several people living
in it so the walls
we didn't realize how thin the walls
were right
and we had a guy living above us that he
was
he was old he was an older gentleman and
uh definitely had
a few screws loosed right because he
uh he said that he would used to work
for the police
right and he would he would he would
bring this up constantly right because
in this in this house that we were in
they had like heavy fire doors right
so so we'd have to like really be
super careful when we were like closing
the doors like there's there's like
letting the doors go
but there's also like because these
doors were so heavy sometimes you just
have to like yank it in
and sometimes that yank was just a
little bit too much power
behind it and it would just like make
make a make a loudish noise right right
and so this guy living above us he was
he you know at the beginning he tried to
be a nice neighbor
and we tried to be nice neighbors as
well um and then it's
we soon came to realize that this guy
had
like massive anger issues right he
he i'm pretty sure like one one day he
could be the nicest guy ever
and the next day he would just like blow
up for like the smallest reasons and
we're just like
yeah we kind of don't feel safe so like
every time every time we'd like uh every
time we'd like maybe
shut the door a bit too loudly he'd at
first he'd like tell us
right be like you please shut the door a
bit and a bit quieter and we're like
sorry
like that that was our bad we knew about
it and so we'd be
extra extra careful but you know when
you go out in and out your house pretty
often right and sometimes
you sometimes you just yank it a bit
loud a bit more harder than you
would uh sorry sometimes you yank it a
bit harder than you intended to
so one time he told us to uh to be qui
to be careful it's fine nothing happened
for a month
and then at around 7pm i just yanked it
and i was like oh [ __ ] that was a bit
loud
literally comes downstairs [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] did i tell you jesus
christ like he literally
full-on [ __ ] screamed i'm like yo
what the [ __ ] is going on and like
from that moment on keep in mind this
was a month after the last time i had
accidentally shot it a bit a bit too
loudly i was like
yo sydney i think we're living below a
crazy guy here 7pm who gives a [ __ ] yeah
and it was 7 p.m as well it wasn't even
in the dead of night
what the [ __ ] did i tell you a month ago
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
and like so i uh so like i you know i i
don't do the japanese thing
i go up to him and i'm not knocking his
door i'm like
yeah bro let's let's let's talk it out
come on come on let's let's let's come
to an understanding here
and so you know i you know we we talk it
out and he's very polite and very calm
he's very calm about it right um and
uh and we're just like look look mate
i'm i'm this is the first place we've
moved to with my new
girlfriend um and he was saying you know
just sometimes walls are very thin so
just keep in mind that i'm right below
you i'm like no i'm totally i totally
get it
after like 10 p.m that's when i'm like
that's when we are super quiet we'd
normally go to sleep because i got to
work the next day as well yeah
um but you know sometimes we're not even
talking at a loud
kind of volume or whatever so you know
as long as you can understand
that we can we are a couple and we talk
as people do when someone else is in the
house then you know we'll try to keep it
down at late hours
cool and so we i go back downstairs
uh literally a week later not even
closing the door this time
i'm literally just having a normal
volume conversation with sydney
um and instead of shouting he starts
walking around
like really loudly like start smashing
down on the floor
like this right like what what the [ __ ]
is going on like well i mean it means
you're like what the [ __ ] is going on so
like i go back upstairs and i'm like
is everything okay are you like are you
having like a stroke a heart attack
what's going on yeah and he was like
look you're being [ __ ] loud and i
just wanted to teach you a lesson
right this is what you get for speaking
loudly i'm just like
what the [ __ ] is going on i'm so like
this is literally
scarred me for life right because like i
i was living
in fear that this guy was going to do
something yeah
because like over time because we lived
here for a year and a half and
obviously our relationship deteriorated
as it would when i felt like in [ __ ]
danger living in my own house and
sydney felt in danger living in in her
in our house as well
and so it got to the point where some
days we'd just be talking and then he
just randomly
like start banging like start banging on
like his fridge doors or like his
cupboard doors like making a lot of
noise when he thought that we were
making a lot of noise and
we were just like talking and having a
normal conversation most of the time
and and event like eventually he went
from the relationship went from me
trying to talk it out with him to being
like
dude what the [ __ ] is your issue and
he's like bro i used to work in the
police don't [ __ ] with me man
if if i wanted i'd call them over i'd
get all my mates i get the boys over and
i get you out
you you like all just say the word just
don't [ __ ] with me and i'm just like
[ __ ] let's sydney we got to move out as
soon as possible like this was like one
of the big reasons
why we moved out and so on the last
night
where we moved out uh sydney was already
gone because she had gone back home
to america so it was just me and a mate
talking and
so it was me and me talking and we were
watching a movie um so we weren't even
talking it was just
it was just the volume of the tv at that
point right
and we get this bang on the [ __ ] door
right
and this guy starts like screaming full
volume
in my face right he's just like i know
you're about to [ __ ] leave
and i'm [ __ ] i'm glad you're about to
[ __ ] leave but like i need to give
you
one last piece of my mind like [ __ ] you
you've been the worst [ __ ] neighbor
of my entire life
and then and then he starts going off
about how he's part of the police again
i'm like
bro calm the [ __ ] down i'm like
at this point this is probably the most
pissed off i've been on i've been in my
life and i'm like
dude monk mode went out the window no no
no no no i'm just like dude
back the [ __ ] off yeah and then and he's
like and then he he looks at me right
looks like he's straight in the eye and
he's like come on have a swipe
go on go on because like i know i knew
he wanted me to throw a punch so he had
a reason to call the police of course
and i'm just and i straight up tell him
i straight up look him in the eye and
tell him
dude you don't know who you're dealing
with here
i was a [ __ ] monk i'm not gonna punch
her
i'm like i'm [ __ ] zen right now
you can try as hard as you like i'm not
going to punch you and he gets closer
and it's like come on it's easy go on
i'm like
dude just back the [ __ ] off now please
i'm gonna re-enter my home
please just [ __ ] off so sad and uh that
was
yeah jesus that was the last i heard of
him and that was my neighbor from hell i
really hope
that no one ever goes through that
because how did you
how did you stay in there for a year and
a half dude um because i was a contract
oh yeah right literally like it was it
was hell because
any time that we wanted and like we
hated
being in that house eventually like
after about after about
six months to a year we just we stayed
at my parents house
as much as we could and then eventually
we just straight up just moved back to
our parents house
because it was it was like a [ __ ]
hell living in that house
um and that's like that's kind of why i
never like one of
that's why i hate apartment sharing now
because that that one experience
has taught me just
i just i just want my own space i want
no one's uh like a noise complaint
actually triggers me now so i'm just
like oh
dude i don't [ __ ] blame you after
that jesus christ
and uh yeah i i had completely forgotten
about that until we started talking
about neighbors
well there you go wow digging up old
traumas
looks like only on trash days wow that's
i've
won nationals jesus christ
i'm sure he's happy i'm sure i'm sure
i'm sure he's happy now i'm sure he's
happy now like i think
i think the early signs were there
because um i'm sure that he won't get a
neighbor who's like
better than you anyway i'm sure he's
probably yeah right yeah because
because like i think like there were
early signs that were there because he
was telling me about the dude that lived
in that place before was also a young
person
as well and he would not stop
complaining about how much noise he made
and how how loudly he shut the door
i'm just like i mean i've shot the door
it's it's loud but it's not like [ __ ]
shake the house loud i probably just get
to the point where i just start making
noise to piss him off and you can smoke
a smack on my
door all day man i've got the sony uh wx
thingies i'm noise canceling noise
canceling headphones were made sure
what are we gonna do break into my house
[ __ ] was this apartment made out of
paper like i think so man i don't know i
don't know
because in uk what is it like 10 p.m is
the official time where you um
make noise yeah so right before 10 p.m i
probably just blast music non-stop and
then the moment tempe emits turn it off
and then rinse and repeat yeah what's
the worst they can do because i was just
trying to be a nice lady
before a number like a certain time and
i think the noise
pollution is below a certain decimal i
think they can't do anything right
actually i don't think they
can donate like legally don't think so i
could be wrong on that i don't think
they can
as long as it's like within a reasonable
amount yeah so it's just it's just the
[ __ ] tax that you pay them
yeah yeah okay okay but you can just
start ignoring him right
maybe he'll take a string maybe maybe
you know what i should have done just
gotten some
nice noise-cancelling headphones yeah
you should have
[Laughter]
people who brag about that kind of stuff
normally don't have the strong ties they
make it out to be you know
no i don't know i mean i feel like he
was an ex-cop for a reason right
he's not a current cop yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] i i don't
yeah i've never really had bad
housemates i've just had housemates
didn't like pay bills
but there's ways of being able to get
them to pay bills yeah i think that's
why
i mean i would argue a housemate that
doesn't pay the bills a bad house yeah i
would argue that as well
would you i'd rather because right what
we would what i would do is because i
was in charge of the internet
and i was the only one because like
these guys i mean they were
my age but they didn't they weren't like
very um knowledgeable
about like yeah about like uh technical
technology technology and like internet
stuff right
and they didn't realize that like if you
had the password to the internet you
could log in and turn off internet to
certain devices
oh okay yeah did you know you could do
that yeah okay yeah so you can just type
in the like what is it like that
whatever the numbers are the 19 whatever
182 yeah and then you can log into the
interest yeah the ip address you log
into it and you can just turn off
devices so i would just they didn't pay
me i would just
turn off all their internet all their
devices that's literally the equivalent
of like your mom taking your switch away
because you didn't do your chores it's
like until you do your chores
no more play time for you yeah and then
they would be like oh
i've got an assignment not much to pay
me maybe i'll put your internet back on
that's a power move dude oh yeah cause
i'm like they're not going to pay me
because they were being [ __ ] so i
was like well i rightfully deserve you
haven't paid me for like half a month
now
uh you know i'm we're all students i
don't have money like yeah this is you
know
i've been paying a bill for four people
yeah you know you can't pay me like 10
quids like
come on that's why like i hated being
in charge of like when you're in
university were you the guy i'm guessing
you were the guy in charge of paying the
rent then
or was it just uh so the rent was
actually done separately but the bills
were done
through me okay and it was only in the
second house that i had a problem the
last house there's only three of us
they were already chill and they all
paid whenever i asked
uh but the house before that they just
never paid uh because they were just
spending it all on weed as
yeah so i was like well i mean all right
well [ __ ] i mean because you always have
that one housemate in uni that just
was never there and never paid for
anything and you'd like
you'd have to [ __ ] hire a private
investigator or something to like get
this
get this guy's money or get yeah get the
money from that guy
it was weird man because like one of my
housemates he was like what
how old are you in second year like 20
barely 20 91 maybe yeah
20 yeah he had like he had a his
girlfriend was pregnant
and then he had the baby and it was just
still so surreal
when i'm like here barely have my life
in order and this man brings his [ __ ]
child into the room and i'm like
and then i'm like what's going on this
is so weird i don't
like this and then i felt bad asking for
internet money i'm like hey by the way
can you pay the bills
i'm like i'm sure you can go like a week
without weeds
just just just pay me bro like give your
kids some starburst or something i don't
know
i think his girlfriend basically lived
at us at our house and i was like
should she be paying some bills i don't
know
i mean it's not gonna be fair i was like
i was like i'm not gonna ask
but i think you should just pay me on
time yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
so annoying cause they because it just
wouldn't get done right unless i did it
yeah of course
no we wouldn't have internet i'm like
well i want internet so i'm going to do
it i'm going to set it up oh and
inadvertently it's in my name
or maybe it was better that was
inadvertently in your name right yeah
well because then i cancelled it all and
i did it um
and all that and i think one time they
didn't pay me
for the last month and they because they
left they were like they just refused to
pay me this video is sponsored by
mack weldon kick your summer off in
style with the brand that's reinventing
men's basics
mac weldon mac weldon is so much more
than just underwear
i'm wearing the pants right now this
t-shirt
polos masks card cases i believe and
many more all the material is
light and breathable it's super
comfortable for any occasion and right
now in the summer
i need that so whatever you're doing
mack welton's essentials has you covered
and they've just brought out the new
macweldon swimline that are quick to dry
and have four-way stretch fabric while
you're not in the pool macweldon's new
maverick techcino shorts and radius
short are the perfect additions to your
summer wardrobe
they'll keep you comfortable so you can
confidently power through your most
active days
merc weldon also has a free loyalty
program called weldon blue level one
gets you free shipping for life once you
reach level two by spending 200
you get 20 off every order for the next
year stay cool this summer and look good
while doing it with the new
mac weldon's essentials for 20 off your
order visit macweldon.com
trash taste and enter the promo code
trash taste that's macweldon.com
trash taste promo code trash taste for
20 off mack weldon reinventing men's
basics back to the episode uh we just
went for a pee break
as i was saying um right before we left
that house the one where they didn't pay
the bills
they actually owed ours i think it was
something like 80 pounds in the end
uh in overdue bills and because we'd all
left the house i couldn't hound them i
messaged them on facebook and they
wouldn't send it to us
and so i had to pay it um and it was
actually me and my friend
who were the only ones who paid bills
and we already we were really close and
i still hang out with him and still
message him sometimes
yeah um really good friends of them and
we both basically paid all our bills and
sold it all out and
yeah so we had to then pay the bills for
two months
for the other guys you didn't pay yeah
we were really annoyed about it because
we were trying to pay and they weren't
paying us
and then i felt like some some cosmic
justice was was given because and
and yeah the god smiled down the gods
are like hold up connor
so it turns out right we'd actually
overpaid our bills right and then we got
a rebate so they'd actually given us
money back right which is actually more
than what we actually owed so
we ended up get given something like 50
pounds back yeah
and my friend was like should we uh
should we give it like equally between
us all i'm like
do you think they would have done the
same i'm like let's just let's just
split it up
how about [ __ ] them it's 25 quid let's
just keep it let's just go to the pub
let's [ __ ] this hell yeah yeah they
weren't going to pay us
i bet if you message them they would
have like replied at the speed of light
by the way i'm trying to send you money
oh yo don't worry yeah
you know i do feel a little bit bad
about it before we require like can i
can i tell the story it's like
[ __ ] that they're stealing the exact
same thing yeah they would have done the
exactly they would have done the exact
same thing
yeah especially if they didn't pay you
as well yeah they literally wouldn't
reply to all messages about paying us
back
and i felt like i felt bad but i was
also like because like i just
would never ever steal but i was like no
but if they're not gonna follow the
rules then why should you follow the
rules
yeah right i feel i feel it's i feel
it's fair yeah i guess so yeah yeah i i
feel like
going through rent drama or some kind of
like bills drama or university is just
like a right of passage
i feel like everyone's had at least one
person that they've been living with
who has just been like the most
difficult [ __ ]
to [ __ ] get any kind of money out of
i know i don't i i just feel bad because
i feel like i'm better than that
yeah i don't do this i wake up on a cold
sweat i'm like what's the statute
of limitations of stealing
i don't know because even though it's a
small amount as well i just i felt bad
but i was like you know what no
[ __ ] them but also like it's literally
like that that good kid does one bad
thing and it's like oh [ __ ] there's a
police
what's the limit to stealing before the
cops get called on me
it's like one week i'm good right i'm
free i'm free
have you ever stolen anything no no
never never
even as a kid hello this is a trash
taste like criminal record
either yeah guys what's the most illegal
thing you've done yeah
me neither yeah okay so you know how um
in the uk you can get um
what was it um like there's like
bakeries in the store and you have to
tell
on the thing what you got yeah and i
think one time
i i got uh like four croissants
and and i i you know i clicked what i
thought was four i went through and then
i came
i went to the tail and i paid yeah
turned out boys
i chose the wrong questions right on the
machine being sad
and it was actually cheaper than than
what it was oh damn i
i i i was absolutely criminal i know i
know so i left the store
i got about like i don't know like 10
seconds at the store and i looked the
receipt and i was like this is not
this is not the uh because i think i
actually got like the chocolate ones
yeah yeah it's not the chocolate ones
this is 20px
and i went back and i was like hi um do
i need to change like pay the difference
and the guy was like
i don't care it's like 20 i don't think
they care
i was like are you sure like i don't
mind paying like i feel bad that i
walked out
yeah with 20 pence the wrong but you're
not going to call the cops right
but he's like dude it's no one's i've
had that before like
i did like the you know when you're like
really really young and you do like the
the accidental stealing like the the
completely unaware stealing
so i did that once like i think i was
like [ __ ] not enough five or six
years old and like in australia
uh there's like newspaper stores where
like people go to like buy newspapers
magazines and usually at the front like
cashier there's like all these like you
know
really small cheap like candies and like
chocolates and stuff like that that kids
can buy and one
yeah yeah and i think i i specifically
remember there was one time i went
because i think my dad had to go like
buy a newspaper or something
back when he was still buying newspapers
and uh i picked out like a candy i think
it was like
10 cents or 20 cents or something like
that i was like dad can i have this and
he was like
bugger off son you're not having that
and we got we got sweets at home
and i remember i don't know why but like
that day i guess i was in like a pissed
off mood or something
i remember being really angry that he
didn't buy me this like 10 20
like [ __ ] pissy little like candy
right and i remember just being like
man like just clenching my fist being
like god damn it what
god damn and father why did you steal
right now no no i was like i'm about to
steal
no i was like i was just like god damn
it's just clenching my fist really hard
and then
we walk out and we're walking to the car
and i'm still pissed off clenching my
fist and then
i kind of look down at one of my fists
and i open my hand i've done that before
the candy's in my hand and i was just
like
slowly putting it in my pocket how did
that get here yeah
yeah because i was like something feels
weird in my clenched fist and i was like
at that moment it was like [ __ ]
detroit become human choices like popped
up here like
do i put this in my pocket or do i come
out clean i was like
put it in my pocket i'm gonna save this
for like actually you know what i did
try and do one time with it
okay so um so you know how like um
like corner stores they don't really
have like the super ultra advanced
labeling price label thing they just
kind of have like those little cheap
plastic paper stickers yeah yeah yeah
like the orange ones
they would put like a pound or 50 pence
at one time i thought like i just had
like a gigabrain thought
i'm going to swap them i'm going to swap
the labels i really want this thing but
i don't have enough i think i've got one
pound it's one pound fifty i'm like i'm
gonna change the label
and i was like heart was [ __ ] racing
going up to the stand like
to the the tail i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] play
cool play cool play cool
and then so i'm you know scanning them
and then i'm like and then as he's
scanning them i realized i'm like wait
he just scanned it
and it doesn't [ __ ] matter what the
label says because the [ __ ] bar code
[Music]
he was like oh it's got the wrong label
on it i'm like oh does it does it
i think the worst thing i've ever done
is um you
like you know when uh in england you
know when they introduced the
self-service machines
which is the closest thing i think
england's got got into a trash system
yeah right and uh on top of this england
within within our lifetime
england has added the plastic bag tax
which wasn't always there
normally you could take as many plastic
bags as you wanted
um normally you could take as many
plastic bags as you wanted
uh but like i think how many years ago
where they introduced the 5p
tax for like in order to
um and i remember this you know this
this one time um
it was it was in a tescos or something
and i had like
i didn't have my card on me because i
just like gone out the house so i just
had like
like change in my pocket and it i i came
up to the till
and it was self-service and it went up
to i the exact
change of my shopping right
but i hadn't bought the plastic bag yet
so i was just like do i put everything
back
now bro if i was working yeah i'd be
like bro yeah
you're not new for having the perfect
amount yeah so i was just like do i put
everything back
run back home which is only five minutes
away and come back
with like with a tenner or like uh like
my card or something to buy this
or do i just press the i have one i have
paid for one bag
no no do i just press the zero bag
option
and i i i i like i like look around i
start like [ __ ] sweating because i'm
just like i'm a good asian boy i've
never broken the law in my life but i'm
just like
check this check the security camera
yeah i was just like check the store
clerk
time [ __ ] stops you know you don't
[ __ ] put the hood over yeah
you know when you feel like you've got a
[ __ ] spotlight on you and i'm just
like
all right i'm just [ __ ] lagging out
how's he still yeah yes
and now that's on camera so yes oh my
god i'm a criminal guy
absolute criminal gear to be fair with
that one i think i paid by card a bunch
and i'd forgotten to put the plastic bag
and
they're literally right there and i paid
my card and i don't cash on me i'm
i'm pretty sure i've accidentally
pressed zero bags when i've taken one or
two bags like so many times it's
it's gone it's the conscious choice
and i it's that i consciously made that
choice
it's the confident press of the body
between manslaughter and murder guys
i think that's why the trust system
works so well in japan because i don't
know if we've mentioned
how they uh how they id for alcohol here
in kombini's right
which is you know they they never asked
they'd never ask for id
if you're buying alcohol here in a
supermarket or a con bean here
because what happens is um you take the
beer or whatever alcohol you want
the uh clerk scans it and then there's
this button
that you have to press in japan that
says i am over 18.
i don't know so sorry it's over 20. now
in england
this wouldn't work any [ __ ] kid would
it would come in
and say yeah i'm over the age of
drinking [ __ ] i remember
how many kids had fake ids and just went
[ __ ] clubbing back when back when i
was underage as well
like but here in japan i can imagine
just like this japanese kid just coming
up and being like
i'm gonna i'm gonna cheat the system i'm
gonna do what's called a pro gamer move
gets up to the cashier and like he just
tries to press the button it's just like
nope can't do it i can't do it
sorry that is literally the equivalent
of like going
to a porn website and when it says like
you must be 18 years or over to like
enter the website like
japanese keep being like like japanese
is like officer arrest me now i'm sorry
had bad thoughts i pressed yes i was
curious
away like [ __ ] turn on anime
[Laughter]
it's so pointless i mean as well in
japan they have just vending machines
with beer vending machines and
cigarettes like
the streets yeah all right okay it's not
until recently that like the vending
machines would like that sell cigarettes
likes finally started yeah like like a
card system to idea because the alcohol
ones
no the alcohol ones don't so like a 14
year old be like what's a soggy and then
they just [ __ ] order and realize it's
beer and
there's definitely kids doing that
i did that yeah okay
but yeah like first time i was working
up in the ski fields i was like 16 and
outside of where i was staying there was
a vending machine that was selling me i
was like oh sweet i don't have to trade
all the way to the other side of the
road at the convenience
store i can't go here police don't give
a [ __ ] if i'm not sure you're like
literally drunk as [ __ ] like in the
middle of a street or something yeah
exactly
exactly yeah like like complain yeah
complain about the statement or
something
i don't know but me being the gaijin in
the snow
if i just come around the corner just
blast me on the spot this man [ __ ]
cracks it open the solid snake music
starts playing
[Applause]
the guy didn't open the beer oh my god
have you guys
ever stolen your parents credit cards
for anything on your kids
oh okay my mom would find out so [ __ ]
fast but
my mom checks her credit card like daily
for like there was absolutely no way i
do
i didn't even know where my credit card
was no no to me money wasn't a system
where you could i never viewed it as a
system where you could game it i always
thought of this i get money i spend the
money that i get yeah yeah like i and i
could i could earn money through things
that was
i never even conceived like i'm not
saying this i think i'm like i'm a good
boy
i literally never even conceived of the
fact that i could take money that's not
even a good boy thing that's just a boy
thing like that yeah i just have to be
compensation i just assumed
the only way to get it was through doing
the tasks that i was allotted
maybe because i played video games too
much and i thought task equals reward
i i genuinely never even considered so
when i hear about these kids who steal
their credit parents credit cards
how is this so [ __ ] normalized like
to me it was never even an option
yeah i've like when i hear that i'm just
like okay you're like a nine year old 10
year old
who just happened to get their mom's
credit card like how did you find that
yeah like i would if i was a
nine-year-old and i was like man i
really want to like
throw a super chat at this v tuber i'm
not gonna think like
where's my where's my mom's credit card
like i'm not gonna like start thinking
like i was like all right let's start
the simulation
where could my mom's credit card
possibly be in this house snake music
starts
like i wouldn't even think about that
right i would rather i'd have more luck
trying to trick my parents by convincing
them yeah yeah yeah exactly like
i think i probably have done that before
more than you don't understand
they're like my favorite vegans yeah
that the ones that put the details in
and they don't like it well you did it
yeah it in
my [ __ ] like you let me do it like
i'm too big brain kids you're amateurs
10 10 year olds nowadays are too lazy
you know
i don't i should make guides but you've
got to [ __ ] inception that idea to
your parents
being like more kids need to be like
darren brown like the [ __ ] big brain
like
yeah convincing like don't steal
convince other people to steal for you
that's what you should be isn't this
like proxy bullying yeah
it's so above me as well because like i
think i was just such a straight edge
kid
right because i think he came to be
honest yeah like even when i was a kid
like i remember
remember the first time i'd ever gotten
anything from this thing called the
tooth fairy
now i'd i'd heard i'd heard about this
thing called the tooth fairy for all my
kids right
from my friends at school all your kids
yeah so so sorry not from all my kids
from all my fellow kids at school yeah
and they were saying like oh yeah if you
uh
if you if your teeth come out you put it
on your pillow get a bit of money
like someone someone once got like a
pound maybe two pounds
they were like i was like damn that's
that's that's a business opportunity
around stealing people's teeth yeah i
was like damn so i remember the first
time
i like had one of my tooth knocked out i
was so [ __ ] excited i was like
my time has come finally the tooth fairy
what isn't me
and like and like i and so i go to sleep
that day
and i what do i find on my one on my
pillow
five [ __ ] pounds i'm just like
holy [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] rolling in here
man
but like also i was a good kid right so
i was like i know i knew my parents
weren't
weren't that well off so i was like mom
you know what i got
i got five pounds but you know what i
don't need it
treat yourself whoa i didn't realize at
the time i found out two years later
i just gave the five pounds my mom gave
to me back to my mum and i'm just like
mom i can't believe i've been swindled
like this
she probably thinks she's pretty money
laundering at its finest there any
prouder moment as a parent than if
you're kidding yeah right
that's literally like the whole bible
tales that you hear about yeah yeah
i feel like literally good samaritan
then yeah i remember they they came into
school and they did like this
presentation one time because
we i oscar wasn't a like christian
school or anything yeah but we did pray
three times a day and
every single story had to be a [ __ ]
bible story right so i thought that was
kind of sad but anyway
they would i remember this one story
they told out just stuck out my mind and
i hated this story so much i thought
this was the dumbest [ __ ] story okay
they would be like what do you want for
christmas you could have
five pounds or a bible and and then it
was like
everyone the first person chose the five
pounds
and they got given the five pounds yeah
and they were happy the second person
got asked for the five pounds and they
got the five pounds and they didn't want
the bible
the third person they chose the bible
and when they opened the bible up there
was 10 pounds in it
and i was like what is the moral of the
story
like even when i was a kid i'm like are
you trying to tell me that every bible
has a tenor in it because i'm going to
go around and look
and there was no tenors and i'm like
wait so so what is the moral like
genuinely now like what is the moral of
this story like even even ten-year-old
me was like
this is dumb this is really dumb like
that's like
that's not and then they were trying to
be like choosing knowledge
over money is more i'm like where's my
hold up
hold up price of the bible's like three
pounds
so wait hold up so what are you like i'm
like and we can't guarantee there's
always gonna be money in the bible
so technically if i get the bible i take
the tenor out and i sell the bible for
three pounds
exactly you know 13 pounds i was just
like this is dumb this is a dumb
dumb shame on you you could have yes
you're so lazy
i know i'm a kid but this is so and this
annoyed the [ __ ] out of me and they told
this thing like three times
in my whole school yeah and every single
time i used to get like seethingly mad
when they would tell this story and no
one else seemed bothered by it they were
like yeah that's a good moral
this is a dumb dumb moral this this is
never a situation you would be
who asks you which gift you want no no
and it's never going to be between money
and a book it's all you've seen
what do you do you want money or this
it's like
maybe the money yeah what is this choice
but it's it's never a it's never a
philosophical question of which do i
want
it's i'm just gonna take the thing that
you you that i want this shouldn't be a
[ __ ] like
a question of my moral standing you're
giving me a gift for christmas
[ __ ] off it's like christmas it's like
which one do you want the millionaire
music
it really annoys me it's just the whole
i
i really really really really really
despise when they try it's really weird
well they try and turn very un-religious
situations or philosophical
situations into philosophical situations
yeah that should
have no right to be i'm like i'm just
trying to buy my homie a present i want
to know what they want
like genuinely i'm trying to be a good
friend if if god wants to five pounds
that's what god wants i'ma give him the
five pounds yeah who am i to preach that
god wants to [ __ ] bible bro he
doesn't want that [ __ ] like maybe he's
not religious you know what i mean i'm
not trying to save him what is this [ __ ]
you want five pounds are you sure about
that
i got a bible and every year i got older
and they would tell the story
i would get more annoyed by it the more
i realized how little scents it made
this whole i don't know if this is a
common thing or something they just told
in my school but they would tell this
story all the time i mean i went to a
catholic high school and i've never
heard of that story
i don't know if it's something that they
made up and this is like that banger
that they kept in
like they're like the person telling the
story
this is the story that gets people that
to like discover christ
it's like oh
it's like you're not a christian yet oh
just and i remember one time connor
tell him the bible story come on come on
come on one time as well
because they used to tell my primary
school and i remember because i
i this is the one that really pissed me
off i just i just remembered this right
now
is that the headmaster of my high school
because
it was the primary school so the
elementary school who told it twice
throughout the elementary school i
remember this because i always hated it
so it stood out
and then i i remember it my head
my prime uh the sub headmaster came in
and
he [ __ ] came in and he started
talking about it i'm like no
don't you dare tell the story and he had
the audacity
to bring in both the props as well oh my
god
and he couldn't just tell the story yeah
he had to ask the kids which one they
wanted
yeah and it backfired because the first
kid he asked he was from the same
primary school as me
yeah so he he knew the answer yeah yeah
and so he asked which one do you want
the bible or the five pounds for
christmas and he was like bible
immediately and he was like which one do
you really want a bible
and he answered me like good answer
that's the correct answer because
there's a tenner in there to reward your
yeah
i'm like [ __ ] off [ __ ] off bro i hate
this this is this sucks i hate this
you know this made me more not this just
made me despise religion even more
from a young age this is not the way to
get kids into religion exactly
like there's better ways to do like it's
literally just tricking them right and
just being like yeah this like
kind of untrue unrealistic thing happens
all the time
take the bite there's just so many of
these religious things that when you
actually break them down a real scenario
just don't work in a way that you're
like just stop just stop
yeah i i don't mind people religion and
all that yeah
i can't wait for like a [ __ ]
jehovah's witness like knock on your
door and you open it and you just see
the bible
i'm just like a thousand again in the
other hand you're just like no
no
just like just shake it shake it shake
the bible
you just grab the
it's just bible dumbest thing why did i
tell this story i didn't know
i don't know i don't know why i told
this story i can't remember
i think we're just talking about sorry
morals
morals is stealing right yeah oh yeah
yeah
tomorrow i'm sorry take the bible
because that is there's a tenor in there
yeah i always take the bible questions
every bible you see has a tenor in this
song
in any other situation just take the
five hours unless you want to take the
bible don't need religion to tell me not
to be an [ __ ] i'm already doing that
frankly i'm trying my best because you
know
when the man in the taxi offered me the
money or the bible i took the money
what is it
excuse me sir i'm
it was all a setup it was all a setup
what kills me is like what christian out
there who's who is like
not who is already a christian doesn't
already own a bible like
that right who out there who just posed
this question be like you know what i
was just looking for a bible actually
yeah man
i needed a seventh copy of the bible in
the house i'll take the tenor as well
thank you very much
this is this has been like one of the
weirdest tangents ever
starting off season two strong i can see
my god i'm still annoyed about it to the
stage
when i go back if i ever go to school
i'm not going to give a shitty talk i'm
going to
i should do an even worse one than that
i'm going to go you know you know what
you should you know what i'm going to do
like
if i ever have a kid i'm going to tell
that story to my kid but
not put the tenor in the bible
but like you're dumb there's one of
these in every single hotel you could've
got one for free
you're not a [ __ ] hustler
so how was this spread out throughout
your entire region
or like i don't know well you know um i
think it's because
the area where i grew up was you know
everyone
every teacher knew every other teacher
in like in the high school
i guess you did live with all the police
you know
odds are is that um you know half of
your
uh school would have you know that all
the teachers at the school
were people who went to the school yeah
and all the people who got jobs were
relatives of people who worked in the
school
right yeah and it was all very
tight-knit very very tight-knit so i
think all the stuff got passed down
and everything that they thought well
this is a good idea just kept getting
repeated and
yeah like yeah bang a story
yeah like stuff you did in like primary
school somehow the high school teacher
would tell you about you're like
how did you know i [ __ ] myself in third
grade how did you know that who told you
that yeah
like how did primary school teachers
still remember like every student that
they've taught
well this is the thing is that this
would be totally unrelated like this
would be a
different school different teacher and
they would somehow know the [ __ ] that
you did
in primary school and you're like stop
talking to each other about me don't
talk
out of school don't talk about me talk
about me in school don't talk about me
outside of school
oh [ __ ] oh okay it's back trash taste
malfunction
guys we all shop online and we've seen
that promo code feel
taunt us at the checkout but thanks to
honey manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past
honey is the free shopping tool online
that allows you to search for coupons
automatically and applies the best one
to your cart honey sports over 30
000 stores online imagine you're
shopping on one of your favorite sites
when you get to the checkout
the promo code field drops down and
taunts you what do i do
well you simply click that honey button
in the top right corner of your browser
and it automatically searches through
all the possible
coupon options available on the web and
automatically applies the best one to
your checkout if there is one and if
honey finds a working coupon you'll just
watch the prices drop
i recently saved 20 on a new pair of
shoes and that's just nice that feels
good honey has found it's over 17
million members over 2 billion
in savings if you don't already own
honey you could be straight up missing
out on free savings it's literally free
and takes a few seconds to install and
by getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting us the boys i use
it myself and i've even used it on
stream before so what are you doing get
honey for free at joinhoney.com
trash taste that's join honey dot com
slash trash taste back to the episode
completely unrelated but i right after
the fccj thing we did
yeah i got two emails from i don't even
know if they're students or teachers or
what from my
high school right uh in welsh uh just
from saying my one of the teachers
misses me or something
what and i was like what how does the
teacher remember you
oh well i actually i mean i i they
remember it's a small school and also
i uh my i think we've had like um
so my brother and my little brother went
there so three generations of ours right
right and i've also
i did talks there you did talk about you
all like went back
oh yeah yeah yeah there which was uh
terrible because i didn't prepare at all
i just went there and i was like what do
you mean
i don't know are you youtubers all we
have to say is i'm a youtuber and every
kid is like
tell me more no tell me about it i'm
immediately interested
actually now i have a frame of reference
so i've done two talks now i've done one
talk at my high school for six form
students which are like 17
yeah 18. um and i've done a talk at my
mum's primary school
for like 10 year olds it was very very
different experience yeah and i way
way way way i enjoyed talking for the 10
year olds way more than i did
the 17 year old because 17 year olds
they're at that age where they're way
too shy
about everything yeah yeah yeah and
they're like starting to get
self-conscious
they hate life yeah i mean i did i mean
everyone everyone remembers that age
and so even though i thought yeah i'm a
[ __ ] i'm a youtuber right this is
like a cool ass job yeah i'd be [ __ ]
i'd be like yeah this is sick i won't
help not like all right so he's got any
questions
[ __ ] no one had questions i'm like
wait what's going on
am i not are you cool am i not cool is
this not epic
it's like are you not being entertained
right now are you
the teacher felt bad for me and he was
like i have a question
oh my oh [ __ ] oh my god did you go to
pewdiepie yeah
you got the you got the pity question
yeah yeah but then i think they started
asking some questions it was all right
it was just terrible and i had to talk
in welsh as well and i'm i
i could talking whilst but i'm not as
like uh able to
express myself as much and watch how do
you say youtuber and walsh
just youtuber oh youtuber so it's boring
same with thai
fair enough on the youtube youtube
channel slightly different accent
yeah do we need youtube just that's it
but um
yeah and uh it was all right it was just
fine i i should have prepared more but i
also
didn't know what to talk about i was
like just just ask me [ __ ] i guess the
ten-year-olds would have been better
right because they were more curious
bro they were great they were like
[ __ ] loving it they were because i
also was doing it over zoom
right and i had my oh you did it zoom
yeah yeah because uh
it was i did this like three weeks ago
oh [ __ ]
you didn't tell me about it you didn't
tell me about this i'm saving for trash
taste oh okay
i got it i remembered
i set up my streaming stuff as a virtual
webcam
so basically i had like my stream set up
up to the zoom
and what i was doing was yeah that's
just my philips hues lights back there
you know
you're like what do you think twitch
show i mean
like all the zooms and the wide angles
and i was like [ __ ] around with that
and doing all the sound effects
the like memes sounds and stuff while i
was doing the presentation for them and
like answering their questions
yeah i was literally doing like live
video editing yeah and these [ __ ]
kids are losing it bro it was so
funny live stream you just did a private
twitch stream yeah basically
literally it was so fun these kids loved
it bro they were like i bet they're like
every time i did like the [ __ ] wide
camera angle they
started like pissing themselves laughing
it was so fun and
uh and they also all watched anime
oh wow which is like great yeah i
remember you saying in the
ccj interview though you're like what's
your favorite anime you said attack on
titan yeah i assume you just said that
because you were just like what's a
popular anime yeah yeah
yeah yeah so these kids are 10 years old
they should be watching attack on titan
yeah
they should not be watching should i
should have said jojo and see if
and these kids are like yes who's your
favorite character i was like captain
levi and they're like yes
and i was like what the [ __ ] what's
going on
what's your favorite sound effect then i
started playing with them and stuff they
loved it they were like
i was surprised because normally the one
question you get from kids is like how
much do you make none of them ask that i
was like wow yeah nice kids very
respectful
yeah because like at that age right like
youtube is still like kind of in the
dreamscape right it's not until you you
hit high school where you're like so
it's worth not going to you
do 10 year olds care about how much
money people make i don't i don't i
think some dude
i never cared at 10 years old i don't
know it depends on the kid but they were
really nice they asked you know they
were like oh
what what age do you recommend starting
youtube that's a tough question
because at once at one point i would
recommend stay as far away from the
internet as possible as long as you can
but
also on the other hand you know getting
experience editing is never a bad thing
like getting good at video editing from
like age 12 it's just great experience
i mean just for life in general like
being able to make videos is a super
useful like and very handy technique
that will come in useful
i guarantee in your life at some point
you will want to make it even in a
corporate job
you will want to make a video at some
point and being able to make a video and
not [ __ ] yourself opening software
is very useful um you know i was saying
you know it's
just being able to learn something is
great yeah it's great these kids are
really good
i was like i sort of i felt like i was
like kind of proud i was like this kid's
good
good kid so they're asking the right
questions
you've got a good set there man they
were like did you like school
i was like of course i did only when my
mum told me to my mom was in the room
now okay
i was like yeah of course and they were
like oh you know they were like oh uh
did you like school and i was like
of course i did that's what i told mrs
[ __ ] but secretly no i didn't um
okay so so this thing was it a zoom call
where or
with where is was it like a virtual
classroom or were they in a physical
classroom they were in a physical
classroom
like a big screen okay and i could see
them and then
at one point i tried to show them my
audio setup thing
yeah and it unplugged and crashed my
whole pc
and i was like texting my mum i was like
mom i'm sorry give me five minutes gotta
reboot my whole pc
yeah it was pretty bad but it was good
fun they were really cute i want to do
that i want to do that
that's really fun
hey lambie heights primary school give
me an email hey blanchington milk come
on come on come on
i'm right there i'm right there man i
was telling my mom i was like oh
sure my mom really wanted to i don't
know maybe she wanted the flex i don't
know
i don't know my mom because they all
knew i was a youtuber but my mom didn't
want to
tell them who i was because my stuff is
not appropriate for 10 year olds yeah
yeah yeah
i was like fair enough i mean especially
trash chases yeah yeah that's not sure
never mind
behind i take that back maybe it's not a
good idea for the kids
to be exposed to mine don't want to talk
about it i don't have to know your
youtube channel
maybe the sixth graders can watch but
anyone below that probably not
just show them the hentai yeah
he's like [ __ ] i i went to a porn
studio
he's my favorite porno yeah perfect
i'll send you the patreon version that's
all right
yeah it was fine i mean the it was way
more fun in the high school because the
high school i just stood there yeah i
was like what do you want to know
no lie oh nothing like you're all boring
we all know what you do yeah because i
guess at that age it's like
you hear enough about like the behind
the scenes of youtubers right because
you kind of
start to like explore further past like
i do
i do feel that like one thing especially
in a small town where i grew up well
you're not told anything about being
able to do anything outside of your
small town
you know the the most ambitious thing
you're told about doing is leaving your
town to go to another university town in
the uk
yeah like the thought of being able to
go to a foreign country and study was
like
never even brought up to me it was never
even suggested to me that was
not a possibility yeah like no one in my
my uh
school studied abroad like that was not
even mentioned
and now i feel kind of cheated that that
was never mentioned to me
yeah because you know i meet people who
studied in all of these countries
and that was just because their school
was like oh by the way these courses are
available i'm like
why did no one tell me this is my this
is like
maybe it's my teacher's fault i don't
know someone should have told me that
this was an option that i could have
done this is something that you know
there should have been more options told
to me
and so i went into there and i was like
listen
the teachers are going to tell you stuff
like you know what they're supposed to
tell you
yeah but please do your own research and
check for courses that
interest you check for international
courses check for stuff that's outside
of
what is being told and fed to you
because there are so much more options
that are so interesting
and way more fitting for you yeah like
somebody who hates
engineering like myself who did it was
never really going to get an engineering
job maybe i would i'd realize within two
three years i'd despise it and i would
quit and go yeah that might have been
like a deadbeat job for yourself yeah it
would have been something i despised
right
and that was just because i didn't there
was no other options presented to me
yeah yeah and i i almost feel like the
system was kind of
failed because it didn't tell me
anything i was just told these are the
courses i can do
yeah and or go to mcdonald's see you
buddy yeah and i feel like a lot of
people
do just it's not a case of people don't
want to do this it's just a case of
people just don't know that it's out
there because i i have exactly the same
experience with you
where the only reason i have a more like
understanding about international
culture is because i come from an
international background and it's an
international family you know
because my family flew over from
thailand that's the only reason i knew
but even
even with that background i had no idea
how many
different paths i could have taken in
terms of like study abroad or have
different kind of experiences like that
if you speak fluent english
you can go and study in any
english-speaking country yeah yeah and
apply for an international student
yeah and you you'll probably get
accepted if you're not if you don't have
like you know a [ __ ] criminal
background
you'll probably get accepted like it's
and if i don't know that i could have
just gone to america and studied i'd
have done that yeah 100
that's like one of my biggest life
regrets is the fact that like i got
offered to like go
study in japan for like two months
during high school
yeah and i said no because i was too
lazy yeah and then legit
the biggest [ __ ] regret of my life i
mean i think i think i always had the
same opportunity to study abroad when i
was in high school and i'm just i just
didn't take it because i'm like well
none of my mates are taking it so why
would i take it exactly
and i'm just like well i'm going to be
away from my friends and family for like
three months yeah i don't want that
instead i went to another [ __ ] welsh
town
but i would have loved to have explored
you know yeah and if i knew that was an
option
i would have gone for it so that's the
main reason why i went to the school to
talk to these kids was because i was
like
tell these kids you know what the [ __ ]
about that's the keys
gotta teach the kids yeah i thought you
know i'd let them know
and just say like yes like you can do
[ __ ] yeah just do
you can literally do anything you want
bro
don't let your dreams be dreams so i
hope
hopefully if one of those kids looked up
and did something and had fun
probably not though because even even in
university there would
there would be like courses where you
know you'd you'd have the opportunity to
study at one of their like sister
universities in another country and i
remember that
they would like you can tell the kind of
people who were going to study abroad
because like they just seemed like they
were up for anything
and i was just like man i i wish i had
the balls
that you had back when i was in
university because i feel like that
would have been one of the best
experiences in my life
or just like a really valuable and uh
valuable piece of experience that
i just didn't get until later in life
right yeah because i feel like
part of part of like this is this part
of
your life after university and
especially during like your mid to late
30s is that you kind of realize that
life just kind of stays the same unless
you
actively search for new experiences and
i didn't realize that until
after after university life attended
that
you know we were just really lucky as
you know
as a kid as a teenager whatever to just
every year you'd kind of get a new
experience but
once that period of your life is over
then you just have to search for that
yourself and it's just not going to come
to you
you got to do that yourself and that's
why like i feel like a lot of people
who we in the same area who we grew up
with they just end up staying
in the same area or they just you know
you go back home and they haven't
changed much right and it's just and
just
that's just because they haven't
realized that if they don't do something
then nothing's ever going to change and
some people are comfortable with that
and that's completely fine but i think
there are i've met enough people in my
life who
have have like this urge to do something
new and do something different but don't
even know where to get started
and i feel like just just go for it just
you miss every shot you don't take right
yeah yeah just just do something out of
your comfort zone
you don't need an excuse to do anything
just take a risk i remember one time my
friend went
and like traveled abroad alone and i was
like whoa what the [ __ ]
you can do that yeah yeah just go
somewhere for fun alone yeah
i remember i thought okay i'm kind of
jealous this guy just had the balls to
do that yeah
and now now i wouldn't mind doing that i
i do i wouldn't it's not preferable but
i wouldn't mind doing it yeah yeah if i
want to go somewhere or you want to do
something you don't have an excuse to do
it you [ __ ] go
still yeah like i was thought i remember
i was talking to a guy
um who had you know uh backman
university and
he was talking about this was going in
his 30s he was talking about yeah i used
to work at this big company
uh and then i just quit and saved up and
just traveled for like a year or two and
i'm just like
wait i thought gap gears would i thought
you couldn't
do that after your gap year that's what
gap she has before yeah and he's just
like no
just you know i just did it because i
just needed change in my life and you're
like
wait but what happens when you go back
how what's you have a career right i
just i just couldn't comprehend
someone just doing something out of
the uh the life path that you know the
career path that
i was taught it's like yeah it's like
the moment you have your career it's
like why would you willingly just
end your career like why would you just
quit your job like that
i mean yeah like [ __ ] if i was in that
position i'd probably do it too you know
yeah sometimes it does take you know
that kind of
massive risk taking to realize that oh
you know maybe it's [ __ ] worth it to
end your career maybe that career wasn't
worth it
be a youtuber
yeah but i feel like especially this
this goes to most like
high schoolers because i feel like
that's that's the point in your life
where you have the most opportunity to
do
something something crazy with your life
not even something crazy just something
out of your comfort zone
something that can increase your
perspective of what happens just try
some [ __ ] out
if it doesn't work out try some
different [ __ ] until it clicks yeah if
you're
about to go to university at some point
and you're maybe up looking for courses
or whatever dude look around for like
international stuff or whatever there's
tons out there
anything that's gonna be fun as [ __ ]
yeah trust me like i i remember
the biggest adventure i'd go i had gone
on it's just moving cities to go to my
university town and
as in england every city is kind of the
same you get
you get the kind same kind of experience
you get freshers weak you go drink a
[ __ ] ton
it's the same for it was like the same
experience no matter what university i
would have gone to
yeah um and i wish i'd studied abroad
i'd wish i'd
done something new and like i
i feel like after i quit to become a
youtuber i i was like gaining back the
gears that i could have had
if i just got out my comfort zone early
in my life yeah i've definitely been
doing that like since
i've gotten like so many opportunities
doing this job i feel like i'm just like
playing a catch-up game of like
i'm taking literally everything that
comes to my doorstep now because
yeah i didn't take any of that [ __ ] yes
back then yeah yeah
i'm like uh and now i regret it being
like oh [ __ ] why was i so
lazy and dumb to like not take these
like now that i look at
amazing [ __ ] opportunities now i know
that everything that comes to me even if
it seems dumb or like pointless or
whatever i'm just gonna [ __ ] take it
yeah i mean i let league of legends ruin
my life so i'm just uh
i would farm at far too many hours in
the legal legends and i'm like i want i
want something but you know what i'm
going to try something else
apex legends i'm going to it's like i
quit league of legends i might try
happiness for once i don't know
[Music]
this thing called happiness what is that
what is this league play as we like
i've heard about that before
oh my god i hate league of legends i'm
so i've never felt more empowered than
leaving league of legends i feel like
wow i have more time for [ __ ] now look
at that
i feel like that's uh i've i haven't
touched a gacha game in a while
and uh yeah a few yeah i mean i've i've
the only reason i haven't is because i
filled that time
with learning japanese and i'm just like
well the glow up if if i'm gonna if i'm
gonna
if i'm gonna have time wasted doing
something every day then i might as well
do it
productively and uh that's not a waste
then gone yeah exactly
so it's not a time waste wow i should
say time
sync because learning learning a
language is definitely a technology
not on our time sink it's like a
four-hour time minimum
and then you get angry after it at least
for japanese you're like
frustrated after it you're not angry
you're optimizing adulthood right now
yeah yeah exactly you know who else
loves taking opportunities and risks our
patrons
i'm just i don't know that's a wow
but i'm sorry if you're a non-risk taker
patron but uh
that that was like a segway that just
veered off and crashed man
i
look at these lovely patrons who are now
funding this new studio we literally
this our patrons are now funding the
studio thank you very much for
letting us move to a place with adequate
sway adequate space
it has been an extremely extremely
expensive move
but you guys have made it possible and
we've got all the new equipment and it
all looks good and
we think the quality shows for itself
absolutely i think it looks banging yeah
we we literally we literally could not
do this without you guys and i know we
said this previous episode where
um you know we didn't expect trash taste
to be as popular
as it was but uh yeah i mean i we
we hope the results there i i just can't
speak today
we hope that we hope you enjoy the
results because this was all thanks to
you
guys we hope the results show i think
we're all slightly tired boys today this
has been a there's been a calm episode
of trash taste definitely
i feel like we've talked about a lot of
this episode we've gone on many tangents
we just came back from like a month
break so like we're slowly gonna warm up
but uh
yeah if you want to support the show
then uh make sure to go over to
patreon.comtrashtest
also follow us on twitter send us your
memes on the subreddit and if you hate
our faces listen to us on spotify
but um yeah yeah that's pretty much
everything uh hopefully
yeah hopefully we hope you've enjoyed
the first episode of trash taste season
two and we'll see you guys next time
look at us look at us
[Music]
you